So, genau, ach es ist ja jetzt ich, es ist ja September, schon seit 20 Tagen, ich hab
noch mal wieder nichts mitgekriegt von, und Leute wisst ihr was das Schlimme ist, Serious
Wachs Tage, 14 Monate, 15, 15 Monate Hypersubscription hier, seht was das Schlimme ist, ich hab's
halt irgendwie, hab ich euch ja schon mal erzählt, ich weiß nicht, also ich glaub nicht,
dass ich wirklich Corona hab, ja, ich mein ich bin doppelt geimpft seit ein paar Wochen,
also da sollte eigentlich nichts passieren, aber man weiß ja nie, man weiß ja nie, ich
muss, ich muss halt zwei Wochen die ganze Zeit irgendwie husten, also, ja das ist komisch,
das ist auch so komisches, so komisches Corona-Husten mäßig, ohne dass das irgendwie so trocken,
wisst ihr, ja, MonkaS, aber ansonsten merk ich nix, ich muss einfach mehr trinken.
Ja Leute, ich hab dieses Jahr darauf verzichtet die Apple-Konferenz zu streamen, ich hab kein
Bock, dass mich Apple für kostenlose Werbung noch mal strikt, sonst hätte ich das gestreamt,
es war ja aber nicht sonderlich viel Spannendes dabei, hab ich gesehen, genau wir lassen uns
einfach levelcap jebaiten wieder, siehts aus, mal gucken, ob es überhaupt jebaiten gibt,
übrigens, wer so nicht mitgekriegt hat, wahrscheinlich haben es eh alle mitgekriegt, Battlefield
2042 wurde verschoben, ich hab es lustigerweise ja schon ein paar mal im stream gesagt, dass
ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass das passiert, ich mein gut, ich sag viel im stream, wenn
der Tag lang ist, was passieren könnte und die Hälfte davon oder sag mal 8% davon passiert
dann auch nicht, aber immerhin, ich kann sagen, ich hab's euch gesagt, das neue iPhone ist
sowieso ein Witz, warum, ich hab mich da mit null beschäftigt, was ist denn, das ist 13
wahrscheinlich, ne, was ist denn, die größte Enttäuschung ist ne Chip, Chip, ok, ok, Chip,
wir hören uns jetzt mal die fachmännische, also einfach die herausragende Expertise von
Chip an, was sagt Chip denn dazu, Chip, also wenn es einer weiß, sind wir uns einig, dann
ist es Chip, Apple hat auf der Kino das ja blablabla, blablabla, Tim Apple war auch
wieder am Start, wer sonst, ok, also was, was gibt's neues, mit hochauflösenderen Kameras,
einem schnelleren Chip und mehr Akkuleistung sind, äh, sicherlich moderner, besser aufregend
als die Smartphones, ne, neue Erfahrungen gibt es auch, ok, Mitternacht und Polarsteig,
gut, das kann er benamen, kann Apple ja immer prinzipiell gut, trotzdem hat man als Apple
Fan am Ende irgendwie mehr erwartet, Quatsch, Apple Fans, Apple Fans freuen sich über alles,
was da so hingeschmissen wird, Apple Fans kannst du auch sagen, hey, ihr könnt euch
jetzt einen virtuellen Fussel, äh, von, oder, oder, ihr könnt euch einen Fussel kaufen
von Tim Cooks Hemd, äh, von der letzten Keynote und die Leute rennen dahin, das ist die Struktur
überhaupt nicht, trotzdem hat man als Apple Fan am Ende irgendwie mehr erwartet, ja,
ich frag mich, ich frag mich nur, was, das ist ja eh der Witz, ne, bei jeder Keynote
der letzten, keine Ahnung, fünf Jahre haben die Leute gesagt, ah, die hat, hat mich jetzt
ganz schön enttäuscht, die Apple Keynote, ich mein, ja, wir haben uns im Stream jetzt
öfters angeguckt, das ging uns ja mehr oder weniger auch fast jedes Mal so, und die, die,
das ist ja nicht die, äh, welche, welche Apple Präsentation war das jetzt eigentlich?
Ich blick da nicht mal durch, die haben ja zwei, drei im Jahr, also, also langsam, aber
sicher sollte man das doch vielleicht lernen, dass man da nicht so viel erwartet, außerdem,
jetzt mal im Ernst, was sollen die denn großartig machen?
Die können ja schlecht, die können ja schlecht ein neues Smartphone, also, die können ja
schlecht jährlich sowas erfinden, wie im Kaliber von, wir erfinden quasi mal im Alleingang
ein Smartphone, und ja, ich weiß, Apple hatte nicht das erste Smartphone, Apple hatte aber
das erste halbwegs benutzbare Smartphone für die Masse, ne, es gab ja so Dinger wie Nokia
Communicator, kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch, kennt ihr noch diese Dinger, Nokia Communicator,
diese alten Dinger, diese fetten, diese Dinger, natürlich, das war auch ein Smartphone, aber
das kannst du doch nicht, das kannst du nicht mehr ernsthaft mit dem allerersten Smartphone,
mit dem ersten iPhone vergleichen.
Weil cool ist, es hat eine Tastatur gehabt.
Genau, ja, sehe ich genauso.
Kaufst du denn ein iPhone 13, ne, kaufe ich nicht, ich kaufe mir gar keine iPhones.
Ich hab das Glück, oder das Pech, ja, das kann man erzählen, wie man will, dass ich,
dort wo ich arbeite, kriege ich alle eins, zwei Jahre ein neues iPhone-Modell, ich hab
überhaupt keinen Bedarf für Smartphones, aber ich hab einige andere Apple-Geräte, also
ich hab meiner Mutter damals ein iPhone SE gekauft, und wir haben zwei, zwei iPads, aber
ich hab halt immer nur ein iPhone, das war es gerade, so die letzte Generation, aber
ich bin gerade am überlegen.
Alter, ich muss die ganze Zeit husten, das ist schlimm, vielleicht hab ich doch Corona.
Ah, so, so, also Apple-Fan, wo sind die, bla, bla, bla, boah, wie viel kostet das?
Na gut, Terabyte, das ist eh so ein Ding, ne, mal ganz im Ernst, also wer sich Speicherplatz
in einem Handy oder einem iPad kauft, der ist eh nicht mehr zu retten, die kleinste Ausführung
reicht in der Regel, ich mein, die wissen ja auch schon, warum es keine Micro SD-Karte
mehr gibt, aber die machen mit dem Speicher so unglaublich viel Reibach, das ist nicht
mehr normal.
Das steht in absolut gar keinem Verhältnis, was die Speicher-Upgrades kosten, wenn du
gibst ein bisschen die Tests kostenlos, ich hab sogar noch einen Test unten liegen, Naso-Check,
Naso-Check-Comfort, Alter, hab ich unten liegen, beim Lidl gab es den, genau, hier, den da,
könnte ich mir mal in die Nase schieben, schnell, wir machen jetzt live Corona-Test, Alter,
ne, machen wir nicht, machen wir nicht, schnell und angenehm, einfache Anwendung, ich weiß
gar nicht, ob das so angenehm ist, ja, na gut, so, und ansonsten sind die Leute halt enttäuscht,
ja gut, who cares, ne, interessiert mich jetzt nicht so, was mich viel mehr
interessiert ist, ich will das nicht vorbestellen, kann auch sein, dass du die Krippe bekommst,
ne, das wird sich anders anfühlen, dann hätte ich Fieber, aber so richtig, ne, ne, was ich
viel interessanter finde ist jetzt, da muss ich euch mal fragen, was ihr zu denken, weil
wir wissen ja, der Chat hat prinzipiell ja von allem, von allem immer Ahnung, so wissen
wir ja, also, ähm, würdet ihr euch jetzt noch ein iPhone 11 kaufen, als Upgrade für
den iPhone SE 1st Generation, warum ist denn die Seite so kacke, dass man hier nicht scrollen
kann, äh, kann ich nicht, äh, weil das gute ist, ja, als Upgrade für das iPhone SE von
meiner Mutter, ich überleg grad, ob ich denn ein iPhone 11 kaufe, ja, das ist jetzt auch
egal, aber ich mein, das ist jetzt billiger, es ist halt ein größeres Display als das
SE, die sieht nicht mehr so gut, ja, ansonsten ist das ja absolut in Ordnung, das iPhone
11, ja, passt mal auf, was haben wir hier, Product Red, Gelb, Banane, Marweiß, Violett,
ne, ne, ne, guck mal, warum gibt es das nicht mit, na gut, 32G ist tatsächlich ein bisschen
wenig, aber das Upgrade ist so krass teuer, guck mal, die Wolle 50 Euro, übrigens auch
geil, wie sie den Preis, wie sie es wegscrollen, wenn du es einmal angeklickt hast, ne, muss
immer wieder, muss immer wieder hochscrollen, die Wolle 50 Euro für 64G, 64G Micro SD kriege
ich für 2,50 Euro, oder, oder sowas, gut, wahrscheinlich ist der Speicher ein bisschen
schneller als Micro SD, aber eine ordentliche, das würde für die Folle ganz reichen, ja,
aber das wollen die ja nicht, hast du ein iPhone zum Eintauschen, ja, aber das zählt
wahrscheinlich nicht mehr, ich habe ein iPhone SE, erste Generation, ne, das zählt nicht
mehr, das ist Recycling, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, das hat Apple wirklich wahnsinnig gut drauf,
das hat Apple wahnsinnig gut drauf, dass sie es schaffen, dass du auf die Seite gehst und
579 Euro siehst hier und am Ende landest du beim kleinsten iPhone 13 für 900 oder so,
das können die wirklich wahnsinnig gut, ja, ich hatte 579 Euro, geht ja eigentlich, das
hätte ich zwar nie gedacht, dass ich früher, dass ich mal sagen würde, das ist ja ein
ganz normaler Preis für ein Smartphone, damals waren so die Top-Modelle für 580 Euro, aber
eigentlich geht das doch durchaus in Ordnung, Marketing durchgespielt, ja, das kostet eine
64G Micro SD gerade, ja, nichts, gut, weil das ist unfair, das jetzt so zu vergleichen,
das normale 12er ist viel besser, ja gut, das normale 12er kostet aber auch wieder
100 Euro mehr, guck und schon haben sie es wieder geschafft und schon haben sie es wieder
geschafft, schon haben sie es wieder geschafft, dass du 250 Euro mehr ausgibst, als du eigentlich
willst, ja, das ist schon, die haben das drauf, ja, nein, deswegen, ich glaube der 11er ist
ganz gut, zumal, Moment, ist das eigentlich so, dass das iPhone SE 1. Generation, dass
sie kein iOS 15 mehr kriegen, wenn die nämlich, ach, Moment mal, kriegen die noch iOS 15,
aha, ja gut, theoretisch könnte ich dann auch noch ein Jahr wagen, weil ich meine,
der hauptsächliche Grund, warum ich gerne ein iPhone 11 kaufen will, ist, weil es keine
Updates mehr gibt für das iPhone SE 1, aber wenn es doch, also gut, ich meine, das Display
ist auch fuddelig vom ersten SE, aber trotzdem, da könnte man eigentlich noch ein Jahr warten,
da kriegt man wahrscheinlich noch ein besseres Smartphone für noch weniger Geld, aber auf
der anderen Seite, ich meine, es spricht auch nichts dagegen, jetzt ein 11er zu kaufen eigentlich,
na egal, wurscht, ne, die 6er Technik kann es nicht sein, nein, das 6er war noch 32-Bit,
das SE ist schon 64-Bit, hier ist eine nice Übersicht der Modelle, die haben aber auch
zu allem irgendwelche Statistiken, oder? Ja, hier, guck, das ist, das siehst du, das ist
ab der 64-Bit-Umstellung, die 64-Bit-Umstellung kriegt das, aber das ist schon wirklich in
Ordnung, also das sind dann 7 Jahre 2022 Support, da kannst du dich eigentlich nicht beschweren,
natürlich kann man sagen, wozu, wenn das noch voll und ganz tut, sehe ich ja irgendwo
auch so, warum brauchen wir was Neues, wenn das noch vollkommen in Ordnung ist, das alte
Zeug, aber da sind wir wieder beim gleichen Problem, was soll Apple jedes Jahr ein tolles
neu vorstellen, die können das Ding ein bisschen schneller machen, die können dem Ding vielleicht
noch eine bessere Kamera produzieren, aber man muss sagen, so die Mainstream Smartphones,
also Geräte, so Mainstream Geräte wie Smartphones, das ist mittlerweile so gut ausgebaut, du eigentlich
braucht man gar kein Neues für einige Jahre mehr, ich meine, wozu, wozu willst du neue
iPhones, oder wozu willst du dir neue Smartphones kaufen, also das einzige, was mir jetzt einfällt
ist vielleicht irgendwelche 5G Geschichten, wobei man sich da auch einfach verimpfen lassen
kann, vielleicht wenn man 5G hat oder Wi-Fi 6 oder sowas, wenn das unbedingt sein muss,
aber ansonsten, mir fällt ja ehrlich gesagt nicht viel ein, wofür man denn ein neues
Smartphone bräuchte, es fehlt der nächste große Schritt, was soll immer das sein, ja,
stimmt, ja, der nächste große Schritt, ich profizeihe euch das jetzt eh mal, also vielleicht
nicht der nächste große Schritt, aber einer der nächsten Schritte wird irgendwas aus
China sein, irgendeine chinesische Geschichte, die sich da übelst durchsetzt und dann auch
mal zu uns rüberschwappt, was auch immer das sein wird, aber ich könnte es mir gut
vorstellen, weil die Zeiten, wo man sich so gelacht hat über China, dass man sagt, hey,
die können ja nur Sachen kopieren oder die können ja nur Sachen billig herstellen, das
ist ja schon lange vorbei, also die Chinesen können natürlich immer noch wunderbar Sachen
kopieren und Sachen billig herstellen, ich meine, erinnert sich da noch jemand daran,
wo ich meinen Controller hier abgefackelt habe mit dem billig China Spannungswandler,
wo es schön geraucht hat, das können die nach wie vor gut, aber die können auch richtig
gute Sachen herstellen, man guckt mal beispielsweise was Staubsaugerroboter angeht, das sind die
Xiaomi Geräte, eigentlich somit das beste, klar gibt es schon noch vergleichbare, aber
somit das beste, was es gibt und das ist China-Chinesen Kram, aber du kannst hier echt nicht beschweren,
wie lange die das ganze updaten, komm mal hier, das SE hat von iOS 9 bis iOS 15, das
hat 16 Updates gekriegt, in 2016 kam das ganze raus, das ist 6 Jahre alt nächstes
Jahr, ne, also das ist doch echt in Ordnung, kurz Chat gucken, ich meine alle 3 Jahre eine
neue Smartphone kann ich mir vorstellen, ja warum nicht, warum nicht, also ich kriege
ungefähr alle 2 Jahre ein neues, also im Prinzip kriege ich immer von der Arbeit die
aktuelle bisschen Budget-Variante, also ich hatte jetzt den iPhone XR und habe dieses
Jahr einen iPhone 11 gekriegt, das heißt ich kriege dann wahrscheinlich in 2 Jahren
einen iPhone 13 oder so, vermute ich mal, also da muss ich mir keine Gedanken machen, deine
Berufsschule ist sehr kacke, es gibt es irgendwelche Berufsschulen die nicht kacke sind, ich glaube
die meisten sind kacke, was passiert mit den alten Phones, die muss ich zurückgeben, die
sind nur geleast und wenn ich zu lange brauche das umzuziehen, dann müssen die Überziehungsgebühren
bezahlen, ich habe das letzte Mal vom XE auf mein 11er, habe ich irgendwie ein halbes
Jahr gebraucht, weil ich den Sinn nicht gesehen habe zu upgraden, habe mir da übelst lange
Zeit gelassen und irgendwann ruft mich einer an von unserem Mobile Device Zeug und regt
sich ein bisschen auf, warum ich das nicht zurückgeschickt habe, ich habe gesagt, warum,
ich schmeiße das Zeug doch eh weg, dann meinte er, ne, das ist geleast, jetzt müssen Sie
Überziehungsgebühren bezahlen, ja, benutzt du VeraCrypt, ja, warum willst du was wissen,
bei deiner Berufsschule ist die Dämmung in der Fassade spontan selbstsetzt, aber hoffentlich
kein Asbest drinne, also wenn das so weiter geht, vielleicht sogar noch das erste Generation
SE dann 16 oder sowas, übrigens, das ist auch so ein Thema, da könnte ich mich wahnsinnig
darüber aufregen, ne, also jetzt nicht wirklich so bezogen jetzt auf iPhones, sondern allgemein,
wie kurzlebig der Kram ist, Tastatur im Arsch gewesen, die letzte, die ich hatte, komplett,
doppelte Anschläge gehabt, dann zwischendrin Logitech Tastatur gehabt, Control-Taste abgebrochen,
abgebrochen, ich müsste es erstmal schaffen, dass die Control-Taste abbricht, so, neue
Logitech Tastatur gekriegt, äh, Maus, doppelte Linksklicks gehabt, warum ist das jetzt so
laut, doppelte Linksklicks gehabt, ausgetauscht, das Zeug ist alles so ein Schrott, sogar meine
Heizung, sogar meine Heizung ist kaputt gegangen nach ein paar Jahren jetzt, also nicht, nicht,
einfach die Heizung, das Mainboard, ups, falscher Feuerknopf, das Mainboard meiner Heizung ist
kaputt gegangen, ich wusste gar nicht, dass meine Heizung überhaupt ein Mainboard hat,
das Mainboard meiner Heizung ist kaputt gewesen, das musste ich dann irgendwie für 600 Euro
austauschen lassen, das hat absolut keinen Grund, warum das so teuer sein muss, alles
billig China-Chinesen-Zeug, deswegen ist halt die Sache, das ist eh alles billig China-Kacke,
warum soll ich nicht einfach billig China-Kacke billig selbst kaufen, wenn es doch eh billig
China-Kacke ist, wisst ihr was ich meine, übrigens meine AliExpress Bestellung ist
da, meine AliExpress Bestellung ist da, und zwar, ich hatte mir ja hier eine Hausnummer
bestellt, sowas hier, ich glaube das wird das sein, ich hatte mir Hausnummern bestellt
mit LED, wobei ich die nicht, nicht die eingebaute LED verwenden will, sondern ich mach da eine
eigene LED Strip rein, dass es so ausschaut, guck, guck, ich will dass meine Hausnummer
so aussieht, ist das nicht nice, ist das legal, klar, warum nicht, du musst einfach eine Hausnummer
haben, ist das nicht Poggers, Poggers Hausnummer, ja und die habe ich mir bestellt, die kam
jetzt an und entgegen der ganzen Befürchtungen, man muss das ja übrigens nicht so machen,
also man kann das ja mit WLED einstellen wie man will, das ist jetzt einfach nur ein bisschen
Show, was er hier macht, was es damit geht, aber es hat schon was, es hat schon was, zumindest
ist jetzt angekommen und entgegen der Befürchtungen, die der Chat hatte bzw. die irgendwie fast
jeder mittlerweile hat, ist das Zeug angekommen, ohne jegliche Probleme, was Zoll, Versand oder
sonst was angeht, ich habe das bestellt, ja, zack, zack, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht mehr
welche Größe ich bestellt habe, ich glaube, ich glaube 20 cm, nicht mit DHL für 48 Euro,
sondern ich habe ganz normal bestellt Standard Shipping und das kam jetzt an vor einer Woche,
bei Aliexpress muss man jetzt auch Mehrwertsteuer zahlen, ja, meinetwegen, ja gut, wenn du auf
Deutsch stellst, du kannst natürlich auch einfach hier auf Afghanistan oder so stellen,
die wollen, lass mal kurz gucken, was bestellen denn Afghanen aktuell, so vielleicht Kugelsichere
Westen oder so, weiß nicht, haben die sowas, haben die sowas bei Aliexpress, ach guck mal,
die liefern sogar nach Afghanistan, aber da musst du keine Mehrwertsteuer bezahlen, wie
nennt sich das denn auf Englisch Kugelsichere Weste, wie heißt denn das, Security West oder
irgendwie sowas, Bulletproof, ok, mal gucken, ob es sowas hier zu kaufen gibt, die China
Kinesen Kugelsichere West, ob ich mich darauf verlassen würde, bin ich, ich bin mir nicht
zu sicher, Technical West, what the fuck, warum kann ich Panzerplatten kaufen, naja gut, das
ist hier wohl, was kostet das in Euro, ist überhaupt nach Deutschland liefert das, nicht
dass ich auch nur ansatzweise dran denke, sowas, geht ja sogar, dass es bei der Amis geht, ist
mir klar, tatsächlich, naja, warum nicht, warum nicht, die China Kinesen, alles klar,
49, naja, und was hält es ab, was hält es ab, Weste Bulletproof, ob ich der China Weste
vertrauen würde, ich weiß nicht, alles klar, Gangster Style, was geht mit denen ab, warum
wird er hier angeschossen auf dem Gerüst, was geht, was mit den Chinesen wieder los,
was ist mit den Chinesen wieder los, ok, es gibt keine, die gezeigten Bilder sind nur
zur Referenz, ja, man sollte sich nicht ans Gerüst hängen lassen, das ist doch keine
echte Kugelsichere West, das ist viel zu billig, das ist doch bestimmt einfach nur Faschingsverkleidung
oder sowas, ja denke ich auch, das kann doch nicht sein, viel zu billig, sowas kostet wahrscheinlich
normalerweise deutlich, deutlich vierstellig, ok, was war jetzt mit Vera Crypt nochmal,
ich benutze Vera Crypt, ja, ich benutze Vera Crypt, die default, was auch immer die stuff,
die da vorschlagen, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht welchen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus,
das default, wahrscheinlich AES, wo man sich, also irgendwas wo man sich keine Gedanken
machen muss, also sowas ist bei meiner Berufsschule nicht passiert, also in meiner Berufsschule
ist nichts zusammengebrochen oder sonst was, die war nur an sich ziemlich im Arsch, ja,
Werner von Siemens Schule Frankfurt, guckt euch mal an, ja nur vom Feinsten hier, nur
vom Feinsten, meine Berufsschule, meine Berufsschule, richtig Hightech, Overheadprojektor, Bild
von 2018, was sonst, Overheadprojektor, so dann so super tolle Außenbereiche, das sieht
aus, ich weiß nicht, wie irgendwie die Abstellkammer aus dem Knast oder so, aber nein, das ist die
Wand von der Berufsschule, die ist eh generell gebaut wie ein Knast, da seh ich das Zeug,
was das hier sein soll, hab ich keine Ahnung, das ist nicht die Berufsschule, aha, Sporthalle,
ja so sah die aus, kann mich noch dran erinnern, ja, irgendwelche Matratzen, das ist der Eingang,
genau, das ist der Eingang und das Ding sieht wirklich genauso hässlich aus, also ich mein,
das ist noch ein schönes Foto von der Berufsschule, also wenn das schon ein schönes Foto ist,
dann könnt ihr euch vorstellen, wie der Rest, guckt mal hier, aber die gehen mit der Zeit,
Fake RGB Beleuchtung, aber schonmal Fake RGB Beleuchtung, ok, Stühle und Tische sind jetzt
noch genau der gleiche Müll wie bei mir damals, Dreck, was auch immer das sein soll, noch
mehr Dreck, ja, so siehts aus, Gutloidstraße 333, da könnt ihr euch vorstellen, die Straße
ist relativ lang, wenn es da Haus Nr. 335 gibt, ja so sieht das von außen aus, nur eins stimmt
hier nicht so, die Leute sehen nicht Gangster genug aus, die da vorstehen, da ist wahrscheinlich
gerade keine Pause oder sonst was, oder es ist 2009, da war ich auch da, Moment, sieht
man mich hier vielleicht, bin ich das, ne 2009 war ich glaub schon gerade mal da, ne, keine
Wurzeln, ich kenne so vom Umfang her, ja gut, meine Berufsschule, übelster Sack, all die
Musik ist mir ein bisschen hektisch jetzt, Wupplik, hab ich doch schon, fast, fast, ja
aber ich wollte jetzt noch, Leute, ich wollte jetzt noch mal eine, ne, glaube ich muss nicht,
ich wollte jetzt noch mal eine Sache sagen, zu dieser Geschichte mit meiner Hardware geht
so kaputt, ne, also ich hatte doch, also erstens eine Sache, die ich mir auf gar keinen Fall
kaufen würde mehr, Corsart Tastaturen, das Ding war von Anfang an, ich mein, muss ich
mal angucken, was der ganze Krempel kostet, ne, guckt euch mal den Preis an für die Tastaturen,
die sind doch nicht mehr ganz dicht, 180 Euro für eine Tastature, Monarch S, was ist da
irgendwie, Goldeinlagen oder sowas, was ist da drinne, zumindest, die Tastature, ich glaub
die hatte ich hier, die Tastature, die ist mega, also, ist einfach Schrott, ich hab das
Ding ausgepackt, angeschlossen, erstens, was mich total irritiert hat, und das glaube
ich geht den meisten, die so ein bisschen so Feeling, wo welche Knöpfe, also die nicht
immer permanent auf die Tastature gucken, die so ein Feeling entwickelt haben, wo welche
Tasten sind, man ist gewöhnt, dass unten links, unten links ist welche Taste, Control, und
wenn du unten links an die Tastature kreist und es ist auf einmal G6, irritiert das, gut,
und das eigentliche Problem ist, dass ich doppelte Tastenanschläge hatte, fast von
Anfang an, totaler Müll das Ding, so, aber jetzt, jetzt das eigentliche worauf ich raus
wollte, ich hab ja die ganze Zeit hier eine Logitech G Pro Wireless Mouse, so, sowas,
sowas da, sowas da, so, die habe ich mir gekauft vor, ja, mit Shocks am Start, WiiWii, so,
die habe ich mir gekauft zusammen mit einem Wireless Mouse Auflade Gamepad, eigentliche
ganz coole Kombination, so, und letztens, letztens ist die linke Maustaste irgendwie
kaputt gegangen, wenn ich hier geklickt habe, also ich drücke jetzt, ich drücke jetzt die
linke Maustaste, dann hat es permanent markiert, anmarkiert, wie auch immer, das hat also permanent
geklickt, wenn man die linke Maustaste nur leicht gehalten hat, so, ich hab vom Chat
natürlich auch wieder zig Hinweise bekommen, so nach dem Motto, ich soll mal Öl reinspringen
oder was auch immer, hab ich alles nicht gemacht, ich hab mir gedacht, weißt du was, ich hab
das Ding ja erst vor irgendwie eineinhalb Jahren gekauft, die tauschen das doch bestimmt aus,
bin ich zu Amazon in die Kaufhistorie gegangen und hab gesagt, hier ist kaputt, da hat Amazon
gleich schon hingeschrieben, ja, ja, nee, das ist zu lange her, schon über ein halbes
Jahr, geh mal zu Logitech, ok, so, dann bin ich zu Logitech auf die Seite gegangen, dann
musste ich erst mal anmelden, ich zeige, also ich melde mich jetzt nicht an, aber es ist
schon hart, hart sinnlos, so, so, du musst, du musst dich, du musst dich, du musst dich
registrieren, also erst mal hier was zu finden ist schon, ist schon der Wahnsinn, Mäuse
und Zeiger, brauchen wir, Mäuse und Zeiger, Gaming Mäuse, so, mehr, pro, pro, pro Wireless
da, so, dann musst, musst du da rein, dann musst du irgendwie hier auf Garantie und dann
musst du sagen, ausfüllen Garantieantrag und dann musst du dich anmelden und wenn du dich
dann angemeldet hast, wenn du dich dann angemeldet hast, dann kriegst du erst mal so eine komische
Auswahl, was du alles durchklicken musst und wenn du dann sagst, hey, ich will trotzdem
einen Support-Fall aufmachen, dann kommt ein Link und du kommst im Forum raus und im, oder
keine Ahnung, in so der Knowledge Base und in der Knowledge Base steht, deine Maus, du
musst erst mal, um deine Maus zu fixen, die Logitech Software neu installieren und da
hab ich mir dann gedacht, so, und jetzt kommt der Punkt, auf den ich eigentlich raus will,
ich bin dann zu Amazon in die Orders rein und hab Support angeklickt bei Amazon, da
bin ich bei irgendeiner Support Dame gelandet von Amazon, die heißen immer Tina, Maria,
sonst wie die heißen wahrscheinlich gar nicht so in echt, hab ich den Support angeschrieben
und hab das erzählt und hab gesagt, hier, ich hab das gekauft, linke Maustaste hängt
und Logitech sagt nur, ich soll die Software neu installieren, kann man die nicht irgendwie
replacen und da hat sie gesagt, ja Moment, ich guck mal kurz nach und nach zwei Minuten
sagen sie, ja, kein Problem, einfach zurückschicken, also ne, wir schicken die neue los, einfach
die alte zurückschicken, hier ist der QR-Code zum ausdrücken, fertig, das war ne Sache
von fünf Minuten, so und jetzt frag ich euch mal, warum sollte ich noch woanders kaufen
als Amazon?
Amazon ist sicherlich nicht der perfekte Laden, aber für mich als Endkunde ist es ein ziemlich
guter Laden, man kann sich sicherlich bei Amazon drüber streiten, was die Arbeitsbedingungen
sind und alles mögliche, ja, ist keine Frage, aber für einen als Endkunde ist das ne super
Geschichte, was meint ihr, warum jeder nur noch bei Amazon kauft, es ist doch kein Wunder,
ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, die Geschichte, ich weiß, ist der Chainlord da, der kann
jetzt wieder schreiben Recycle Story, ich kann mich noch an Dinge erinnern, wo ich mal im
normalen Laden versucht habe, Hardware umzutauschen, das ist ein Riesenakt, die legen einem da
so Steine in den Weg, ich musste mal einen Drucker, ich hab mal vor Ewigkeiten einen
Drucker, also das ist so die schlimmste Serviceerfahrung, die ich jemals hatte, ich hab mal vor ne Weile,
ganz ganz lange her, da gab's noch Phobis, gibt's die noch, Phobis, tatsächlich Phobis
gibt's noch, übelster Schrottladen, Alter, Phobis, die Phobis Story, ja, keiner braucht
euch mehr, ist die Phobis Story, zum Glück, ähm, zumindest, ich hab meine Druckerpatrone
gekauft, bei Phobis, also schon ganz lange her, das war die schlimmste Serviceerfahrung,
die ich je hatte, und bin heimgekommen, die hat Schlieren gedruckt, ich mein, woran soll
das bitte schon sonst liegen, außer dass die Patrone kaputt ist, bei diesen Billigdruckern
tauschst du mit der Patrone alles aus, Köpfe, Tinte, alles, warum sollte mein Drucker Schlieren
drucken, mit der alten Patrone nicht und mit der neuen Patrone würde das Schwachsinn machen,
also hab ich die Patrone genommen, bin wieder hingefahren zu Phobis und hab gesagt, Leute,
die Patrone ist kaputt, ich brauch eine andere, dann haben die gesagt, das glauben sie nicht,
die ist nicht kaputt, hab ich gesagt, wie soll ich euch das jetzt beweisen, ich mach mir
aber hin und zurück zu fahren, und das lief dann darauf, was lange Rede, kurzer Sinn,
ich musste dann, also sie wollten zum umtauschen, meinen Drucker damit hinbringen, dass sie
dann sehen, dass der, äh, Schlieren druckt und war mega unfreundlich, Alter, ich wär
dir gerne am liebsten, damals schon, da war ich aber noch klein, mit dem Arsch ins Gesicht
gesprungen, so, und bei solchen Dingern, musst du dich doch nicht mehr wundern, wenn die
Leute einfach zu Amazon gehen, Amazon hat eigentlich die beste, also, vor allem, gerade, dass sich
dann noch die Leute im Einzelhandel beschweren, dass keiner mehr zu ihnen geht, ja klar, weil's
bei Amazon easy as fuck ist alles, der einzige Vorteil, den du hast, ist, dass du's direkt
bekommst, wenn du lokal in Geschäft gehst, weil, normalerweise ist es ja so, also ich
weiß nicht, wie's euch geht, aber bei mir ist es so, ich überleg mir meistens eine
ganze Weile, ob ich was haben will oder nicht, aber wenn ich mich dann dazu entschieden habe,
was ich es haben will, dann muss das schnell gehen, kenn ihr das, so nach dem Motto, ah,
soll ich mir das jetzt kaufen, soll ich mir einen Rechner kaufen, soll ich mir eine Maus
kaufen, soll ich mir einen Fernseher kaufen, soll ich mir eine neue Konsole kaufen, ja,
hm, soll ich das machen, soll ich das machen, und wenn ich dann sag, ja, ich mach's, dann
sag ich, bäm, das muss jetzt, jetzt sofort da sein, so, und das ist der einzige Vorteil,
den irgendwelche Geschäfte vor Ort haben, dass du dann schnell hinfahren kannst, und
sagen, hier, gib mal her, äh, ich hab's direkt, aber, aber, mittlerweile ist es so, Amazon
ist so schnell und so unkompliziert bei allem drum herum, sogar teilweise Same-Day-Delivery,
das ist keinerlei Vorteil immer, im Laden zu kaufen, außer, dass du Stress hast, wenn
irgendwas nicht funktioniert, weil Amazon macht die einzig sinnvolle Taktik, die, neben
den Durchschnitt, also, was ich damit meine ist, also, zum Beispiel Amazon Logistik, ich
weiß nicht, wer schon mal die Ehre hat, von Amazon Logistik beliefert zu werden, ich geh
mal davon aus, die meisten, ja, Amazon Logistik ist ja im Prinzip auch nur Subunternehmer,
Subunternehmer des Subunternehmers, des lokalen Subunternehmers und der Fahrer als Subunternehmer,
also der Fahrer kriegt am Ende 1,50 oder so, keine Ahnung, also, ist im jeden Fall, auf
jeden Fall ziemliches Ausbeuter-Ding, geh ich mal ganz stark von aus, aber, die Taktik
bei Amazon, die Logistik ist folgende, Scheiß auf Sicherheit bei Zustellung, so nach dem
Motto DHL musst du unterschreiben, wobei DHL unterschreiben von wegen, ja, passt mal auf,
von wegen DHL unterschreiben, letztens ist der DHL-Typ, ist sie nicht niedlich, letztens
der DHL-Typ, ich hab ein Foto gemacht von der Kamera, ich hab ja ne Kamera oben, mittlerweile,
das ist der Gehweg vom Haus, da liegt einfach, da liegt, also hier ist das Hoftor, da liegt
einfach das Paket, der Typ hat geklingelt, ich bin drangegangen, hab gesagt, ja, Moment,
ich komm ans Fenster, und als ich am Fenster war, war der Typ im Auto und ist abgehauen,
und das Paket lag einfach mitten auf dem Gehweg, ich hatte nix an, großartig, ich konnte noch
nicht mehr raus, ich muss dann erstmal hoch, mich anziehen, auf die Gass, also, kannste
nicht sein, zumindest Amazon macht ähnliche Taktik, aber, aber bei Amazon ist es folgendermaßen,
das Paket ist happy, ja, aber bei Amazon ist es folgendermaßen, Amazon, also geh ich ganz
stark von aus, Amazon kalkuliert das anders, Amazon macht ja standardmäßig keine Unterschrift
und Amazon wirft standardmäßig auch Dinge auf gut Glück einfach übers Hoftor, weil
die denken sich, das spart uns so viel Zeit, dass wir das alles nicht machen müssen, und
in den 1% der Fälle, wo es nicht funktioniert, bezahlen wir es halt, stell euch mal vor,
die pfeffern mal eine neue Maus übers Hoftor, und die geht dabei kaputt, so, was mach ich
dann, ich lass mir von Amazon eine neue schicken, aber, das passiert in vielleicht 1% der Fälle,
dass die Zeit, die die sparen mit nicht lange zustellen, ist wahrscheinlich billiger, als
das die ab und zu mal bezahlen müssen, dass das kaputt geht, und so machen die das anscheinend
auch, wenn du Sachen zurückschicken willst, die gehen wahrscheinlich in dein Profil gucken,
also ich geh davon aus, dass der Amazon Support Mitarbeiter geht in dein Profil gucken, ob
du so notorischer Zurückschicker bist, so 8% der Dinger, dann machen sie es vielleicht
nicht, aber die sehen bei mir, der Typ, der gibt tausende, zehntausende Euro hier bei
Amazon aus, und schickt so gut wie nix zurück, da sind wir einfach mal nett zu dem, dass
der weitere 10.000 Euro bei uns auskippt über die nächsten Jahre, und das ist ja auch nicht
dumm von Amazon, weil genau das mach ich, ja, so siehts aus, deswegen alle nur bei Amazon,
und wie schlechter Support, wie schlechter Support aussehen kann, hab ich letztens wieder
gemerkt, bei Microsoft, ich hab angerufen bei Microsoft, äh, wir haben, äh, Azure,
Azure Probleme gehabt, ähm, ja, hier, wir haben angerufen bei, also ich hab angerufen
beim Azure Support, Leute, das könnt ihr komplett vergessen, ich hab irgendein Inder dran, der
hieß irgendwie Gang, Gangkhan Dieb oder so, ich kann den Namen mir schon gar nicht mehr
sagen, was war, Indischer Name Gang, nee, Gang, nee, nicht, nee, äh, ach, keine Ahnung,
Indische Namen, nicht Gandhi hier, zumindest, er hat null gecheckt, ich habs 50 mal erzählt,
äh, es war zumindest komplett, komplett sinnlos, es geht immer noch um die gleiche Geschichte,
die ich euch letztens erzählt hab, dass, äh, File Geschichten in Azure so langsam sind,
und im Prinzip kriegst du von Microsoft Support als Antwort immer nur das, was du eh schon
ins Ticket geschrieben hast, noch mal hinten drauf, so, und der Hit kam dann zumindest
am Ende, da meinte er zu mir so, also es hat sich null, es hat überhaupt nichts gebracht,
im Prinzip einfach die gleiche Sache erzählt, noch mal, die schon im Ticket drin stand,
und ich meine, es bringt jetzt nicht viel, und dann meinte er am Ende zu mir so noch
so, thank you for call, no need to worry, hab ich mir auch gedacht, ja, alles klar, ok,
ich muss jetzt noch mal irgendeinen anrufenden Ahnung hat, also das war halt kacke Support,
Microsoft ist aber auch Spezialist drin, sinnlose Supportantworten zu geben, ihr müsst euch
mal die offiziellen Supportantworten angucken von irgendwelchen Tickets, also nicht von
Tickets von, äh, so Hilfe, Hilfeanfragen aus diesem Microsoft Support Form, die sind
so unsinnig, schwachsinnig, wie die immer beantwortet werden, aber das ist, aber das
ist nicht nur, das ist nicht nur da, eines der bescheuertsten Support Sachen, die ich
im Internet letztens gesehen hab, ist folgendes, warte mal, WhatsApp Video Call Locked iPhone,
mal gucken, ob ich das noch mal finde, hier, ah, das ist, das ist auch geil, das ist hier,
das ist hier der Apple Community Spezialist, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob da wirklich einer
von Apple ist, aber das ist auch so ne, das ist ne typische Support Anfrage, wie sie einfach
sinnlos beantwortet wird, also der Typ fragt hier, wie kann ich einen WhatsApp Video Call
annehmen, wenn mein, also vom Locked Screen die Antwort ist, das geht nicht, du kannst
den Call annehmen, musst aber unlocken für Videofunktionalität, das ist das die korrekte
Antwort, aber guckt euch mal an, wie bescheuert die Support Antwort ist, das ist, das ist
Schwachsinn, das stimmt überhaupt nicht, er will nicht, er will nicht Calls annehmen,
er will Video Calls vom Locked Screen annehmen, das ist was komplett anderes, das ist so,
das ist so ne typische Textblock Schwachsinn Support Message, die du mittlerweile am laufenden
Band bekommst, sei es bei Microsoft oder hier in dem Fall, sei es bei Apple, sei es bei
Google, sei es bei, was weiß ich, bei allem Möglichen, so diese, diese Textbox Antworten,
die absolut keinen Sinn ergibt, das ist nicht das, was er gefragt hat, er hat gefragt Video
Calls und Video Calls sind was komplett anderes, als Calls annehmen vom Locked Screen, totaler
Schwachsinn, ja weil ich hab letztens auch danach gesucht und hab diese Support Message
gefunden, deswegen ist mir das hier gerade aufgefallen, so, ich weiß gar nicht wer Sunrise
ist, wer ist denn Sunrise, Sunrise Communications, ah das ist, ah Schweiz, Schweiz Internetstells,
ja, ja gut, Microsoft, das siehst du ja schon an Windows 11, ja das kann sein, das kann
sein, dass der irgendwie so nen ähnlichen Namen hat, ja, Microsoft, das siehst du ja
schon an Windows 11, das ist irgendwie total unsinnig alles, was sagst du zu Azure und
der OmniGod Lücke, eh gar nichts, was soll ich da großartig zu sagen, das ist viel viel
schlimmer aufgebauscht, als es eigentlich ist, also das hier ist irgendein Management
Service von Microsoft, der standardmäßig auf Azure VMs vorinstalliert wird und darüber
kann man relativ trivial, wenn das ansprechbar ist, Lücken ausnutzen, das Problem ist nur,
was bei den meisten Artikeln darüber vergessen wird, dass nichts davon im Internet hängt
standardmäßig, du kommst überhaupt nicht von außen da dran, also, ja die Lücke an
sich ist mal wieder Lull, aber es hat kaum Auswirkungen, nutzt vera Kript in einer Hardware
gebundenen Key oder wie verhält sich das, wenn man die Platte in einem anderen PC tut,
wenn du die Platte in einem anderen PC tust und von der Platte bootest, musst du ganz
normal das Passwort eingeben, ne ne, das funktioniert, das funktioniert, also vera Kript macht das
folgendermaßen, wie das funktioniert, ich zeig dir das, für alle die keinen Bock haben
Bitlocker oder irgendein Microsoft Zeug zu verwenden können, vera Kript verwenden übrigens
die einzige Software aus Frankreich, was ist das für Musik, oh das ist Splatoon oder
sowas, wer keinen Bock hat Bitlocker oder sowas zu verwenden kann vera Kript verwenden,
das ist quasi das was früher TrueKript war, bloß Baguette, kannst du Festplatten voll
verschlüsseln, also wie die das machen ist folgendermaßen, wenn man vera Kript startet
und seine Festplatte voll verschlüsselt, dann funktioniert das folgendermaßen, die installieren
erstmal den eigenen Bootloader, in diesem Bootloader muss man dann ein Passwort eingeben zur Festplatte
entsperren beim booten, aber das ist nicht etwa so, dass eure Festplatte mit eurem Passwort
verschlüsselt ist, so einfach ist das nicht, vera Kript generiert, vera Kript ist doch
auch unsicher, nee warum sollte das unsicher sein, vera Kript generiert beim Setup Vorgang
für die Festplatte, generiert das ziemlich lange geheime Schlüssel, der wird am Anfang
der Platte geschrieben und am Ende der Platte geschrieben, warum, falls die Platte mal beschädigt
ist kann ich immer noch den Key auslesen, weil er zweimal auf der Platte steht, dieser
Key wird verschlüsselt mit eurem Passwort, also sprich was eigentlich passiert ist beim
booten, ihr gebt beim booten euer Passwort ein, das mit dem Passwort entschlüsselt ihr
den Key auf der Platte und der Key entschlüsselt die restliche Platte, warum sollte man keinen
Bitlocker verwenden, ja vielleicht traut man Microsoft nicht, übrigens danke für die
Subs Leute, ich muss mal kurz gucken, wieder Hälfte übersehen, 11 Monate, Leko ist auch
wieder am Start, 9 Monate, Leko hat 12 Monate, die Hypersubs encryption, nice, TAX, GG Eats,
dumme Frage, was bringt Bitlocker wenn man Windows Login umgehen kann, das bringt an der
Stelle gar nichts, wichtig ist, dass die Platte verschlüsselt ist und du ohne Passwort gar
nicht an die Platte dran kommst, also wenn dein System bootet ohne Passwort bis zu Windows
Login, dann ist das unsinnig, du brauchst beim booten, also bevor die Festplatte überhaupt
zugreifbar ist, da musst du ein Passwort eingeben, ansonsten ist das sinnlos, ich weiß nicht
ob Veracrypt Secureboot geht, keine Ahnung, so brauche ich Secureboot, ja es wurde ja verschoben,
aber wie gesagt habe ich ja schon hoffe Zeit, dass das wahrscheinlich so sein wird, hatte
ich mal wieder recht, bei 80% der Sachen wo ich nicht recht habe, erwähne ich jetzt halt
einfach nicht, so was gucken wir uns denn heute mal an, wo wir es gerade von Amazon hatten,
ich hatte doch irgendein Video hier, was mir vorgeschlagen wurde, Why I Quit Amazon, Amazon
Software Engineer, weiß nicht warum mir das vorgeschlagen wird, aber jetzt können wir
uns mal anhören was er sagt, Why I Quit, bisschen leise, bisschen sehr leise, die Audio
Quali ist richtig mies, Mist was war jetzt mit BitLocker und Veracrypt, äh wie was soll
das gewesen sein, ich hoffe jetzt ist es laut genug, wow Alter ist ja gut, 1KS, traurig
schön, 10 Subscribtions, stell so 19 Monate noch mal Hypersubscriber her, danke, danke
Leute, zeig mal her, wer hat Glück gehabt, Lun, 1, 2, ne, 2, 5, 6, 8, Serio, Denkpepp,
Jockelbar, Nils, B, Bremer, Xenom, Live, Ofenkartoffeln, LTD, Basti, AndiXTV und Crysis666, jawoll,
wer hat gedodged, ja, Elfless Chat hat gedodged, ok, was sagt er denn, moin JVpeek, nimmst
du Chromium, ja, warum nicht, ich habe alles mögliche, also warum hat er gequittet bei
Amazon, also muss ich sagen, die Beleuchtung und der Sound ist vielleicht nicht die beste
vom Video, aber er ist ja auch Softwareentwickler, musst du es nicht können, ja erzähl, lass
mich raten, lass mich raten, ich predikte mal, warum er keinen Bock hatte auf Amazon,
weil Amazon absolut Toxic Work Atmosphäre haben muss, von allem was man so liest und
hört, dementsprechend haben die auch wohl eine wahnsinnig hohe Fluktuation, also es
bleibt wohl kaum länger einer als irgendwie 2, 3 Jahre bei Amazon, ok, ich hab, es hat
gerade irgendeinen Sound gemacht, aber, ich glaube das sind immer noch die Subs, die zu
langsam sind und rein pendeln, kann das sein, ja, lull, die Sounds sind delayed, alter, guck
mal, das ist broken AF, wie hast du dein TTS für dein Memeport gemacht, du meinst das
hier, du meinst sowas hier, nee, ach Quatsch, du meinst das hier, oder, äh, das ist ein
koreanischer Text-to-Speech-Service, ok, gucken wir mal, ok, ansonsten da war auch
nur ein Jahr da, die haben alle keinen Bock darauf, hä, hab ich das richtig verstanden,
er hat nach 3 Monaten keinen Bock mehr und war dann 13 Monate da, Pfeifettmove, na gut,
vielleicht hat er ja seine Gründe für, aus dem Weg geringen Verdiener, ah, siehste, siehste,
ok, also, bei uns haben Arbeitgeber in Deutschland allgemein keine Benefits, oder selten, selten
und zumindest nicht in dem Ausmaß, wie das in den USA teilweise gang und gäbe ist, also
wenn du hier, hier hast du Glück, wenn sie sich beteiligen an deiner Monatsfahrkarte oder
sowas, alter, alter, wäre ich da sofort dabei, stell dir mal vor, ihr kriegt komplett Verpflegung
Essen umsonst von eurem Arbeitgeber, wir haben eine eigene Kantine, na, das ist wirklich
eigen ist die nicht, äh, wir haben eine Kantine, wo wir, äh, ein bisschen günstiger Essen
bekommen, das ist alles, jawoll, ok, na gut, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein
Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding,
ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das
ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein Ami-Ding, ok, das ist ein
Free Starbucks Kaffee.
Ja, das gibt's.
A hundred dollars to spend on amazon.com per year.
Oh, das ist aber großzügig von Amazon, 100 Euro Gutschein im Jahr.
Gut, natürlich könnte man jetzt sagen, sie müssten es auch gar nicht machen.
Aber...
Naja, vielleicht ist es nicht so viel.
That's literally it, nothing else.
It made its impact to the local community though.
It killed the local banana market because nobody was buying bananas from the grocery stores anymore.
I'll say that it's really competitive.
I honestly can't say most of my co-workers were actually co-workers.
Everyone kinda felt like they were my competitors.
Das hab ich auch schon gelesen.
It's short for a performance improvement plan in Amazon.
And if you get that and you get pipped...
Performance improvement plan.
Allein schon...
Wisst ihr was ich geil finde?
Das ist ja auch eine Sache.
Das hat sich so die letzten Jahre, Jahrzehnte über eingeschlichen.
Dass man Dinger nicht mehr so nennt, wie sie eigentlich sind.
Sondern das so umschreibt.
Performance improvement plan.
Heißt auf gut Deutsch, du suckst.
Eigentlich haben wir keinen Bock mehr auf dich.
Aber vielleicht können wir noch irgendwas machen.
So nach dem Motto, wenn du dich jetzt ganz besonders stark anstrengst und no lives,
und alles skippst für die Firma, dann hast du vielleicht noch ne Chance.
Also im Prinzip umschreibt das eigentlich nur so nach dem Motto,
eigentlich haben wir keinen Bock mehr auf dich.
So nach dem Motto willst du nicht woanders hin oder was auch immer.
Aber jetzt ist es Performance improvement plan.
Klingt nicht so schlimm.
Ist genauso ein Ding wie PTSD.
Ist auch was, was komplett harmlos klingt mittlerweile.
Ich meine, wer stellt sich denn ernsthaft, wenn er das das erste Mal hört,
was Schlimmes unter einer posttraumatischen Belastungsstörung vor?
Die meisten Leute können sich glaube ich gar nicht ausmalen,
was das für betroffene Leute bedeutet.
Es hört sich auch gar nicht so schlimm an.
Vor allem wenn es dann noch mit PTSD abkürzt,
dann hört sich das ja noch mal, noch weniger schlimm an.
Wisst ihr, wie man das im ersten Weltkrieg genannt hat?
Damals hat man gesagt Shell-Schock dazu.
Man ging damals von aus, dass das durch irgendwie Druckwellen von
Geschossen und so ausgelöst wird.
Was ja nicht stimmt, aber hat man sich damals gesagt,
das klingt nach richtig Impact und richtig gefährlich.
So und das wurde jetzt über die Jahre immer weiter verwässert,
bis wir mittlerweile bei posttraumatischer Belastungsstörung rausgekommen sind,
wo sich keiner irgendwas Schlimmes mehr drunter denkt,
was natürlich immer noch für die Profen genauso schlimm ist wie vorher.
Also das haben wir die letzten Jahre wirklich perfektioniert.
Du darfst ja auch nicht mal sagen, zu irgendeinem Alter bist du dumm.
Das ist ja auch ganz gefährlich.
Es geht nicht.
Das musst du dann wahrscheinlich umschreiben irgendwie anders.
Das würde ich mir eher in China vorstellen, wenn Leute ohne irgendwelche Wörter einfach verschwinden.
Aber das muss ich jetzt nochmal abwarten.
Was, was, was, was?
Manager getting demoted.
Okay, das ist was, das fände ich.
Das könnten wir uns von Amazon abgucken.
Manager, die Sacken werden einfach ent...
Was ist denn das Gegenteil von befördert?
Haben wir überhaupt degradiert?
Heißt das glaube ich auf Deutsch?
Das, das könnten wir eigentlich auch machen.
Manager, die Sacken werden wieder degradiert,
zu wo sie weniger Probleme anrichten können.
Und das, finde ich, ist eigentlich eine sehr sinnvolle Maßnahme.
Ja, das ist auch ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Also man kann nicht von den Leuten erwarten, dass sie kreative Arbeiten verrichten,
wenn sie permanent Angst haben vor irgendwas.
Das kann man Stonks Leuten eigentlich nicht oft genug sagen.
Also egal was es ist, Angst oder zu viel Druck, der ausgeübt wird,
irgendwelche Sachen, um den Leuten das Leben schwer zu machen,
das führt in der Regel nie dazu, dass es in kreativen Berufen bessere Ergebnisse gibt.
Funktioniert nicht.
Das habe ich auch schon total auf den Videos gesagt, aber das klappt einfach nicht.
Kreativ, natürlich.
Ist das jetzt irgendein Ding, wo dein Geld von abhängig ist?
Ne, so wie ich das jetzt verstanden habe, ist das einfach nur eine Seite,
wo du intern halt eben sehen kannst, wie lange du dabei bist und sowas.
Da siehst du mal, der Typ ist ein Jahr bei Amazon,
ist bei der Hälfte schon angelangt, der Beschäftigten, also wie lange die dabei sind.
Dann kommt das ja ungefähr hin, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe,
oder was ich jetzt schon öfters gelesen habe,
dass die eine extrem hohe Fluktuation haben, also sogar noch höher
als die ganzen anderen Technik-Giants-Dinger da aus den USA.
Gerade bei Microsoft ist es ja wohl mittlerweile so,
dass sie nicht nur händeringen Mitarbeiter suchen,
also man weiß ja nur, was man drüber liest,
nicht nur händeringen Mitarbeiter suchen, die Ahnung haben,
sondern dass sie auch versuchen, aktiv wirklich aktive Mitarbeiter zu halten.
Amazon denkt sich aber, braucht man nicht.
Es ist ein Jahr her, seit ich bei Amazon gearbeitet habe,
und ich war bereits bei dem 50. Prozentile in ihrem Chart.
Ich habe vorhin gesagt, dass Geld und Kompensation
nicht die wirklich wichtigste Sache für mich sind.
Ich bin nicht allein in diesem Sinne.
Ich habe schon genug über die Arbeitskultur von Amazon gesprochen,
und wie der Name der Firma sagt, ist es wirklich ein Dschungel,
in dem man überleben muss.
Wiederholen Sie mich nicht falsch, Amazon ist eine tolle Firma.
Sie sind eine der Fans, sie bezahlen Software-Engineer auch.
Sie haben über die vergangenen wenigen Jahre
sehr viel Geld verdient.
Und ich habe vor einigen Zeiten erwähnt, dass sie dir Bananen gratis geben.
Und obwohl Amazon so notouristisch ist,
denke ich immer noch, dass Amazon eine tolle Firma ist,
eine tolle Arbeit und ein toller Ort zu haben.
Aber wie kann das wirklich sein?
Also insgesamt kann ich mir vorstellen,
dass es tatsächlich keine schlechte erste Station ist,
bei Amazon gewesen zu sein.
Das ist halt ein Luxus, sehe ich ganz genauso wie er.
Das ist aber halt ein Luxus,
den sich leider viele Leute nicht aussuchen können.
Er hat jetzt gesagt, so nach dem Motto,
was bringt es ihm, wenn das irgendwie eine super tolle Firma ist,
wenn er da nicht glücklich ist, was macht er da noch?
Gebe ich ihm voll und ganz recht,
ich könnte mir das auch nicht vorstellen,
irgendwo zu arbeiten, wo ich jeden Morgen kotzen muss,
wenn ich auf die Arbeit fahren muss.
Leider haben diesen Luxus nicht so viele.
Es gibt genug, die müssen täglich zur Arbeit
und die hassen ihren Job.
Das ist was, das würde ich generell nicht von meiner Arbeit erwarten.
Bei den Amis ist es vielleicht anders,
aber ich sage jetzt mal so, wie es ist.
Die Dinge, die ich auf der Arbeit mache,
sorgen nicht unbedingt dafür, dass ich wirklich mehr lerne.
Ich kriege vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Praxiserfahrung
oder ein bisschen mehr Routine in manchen Sachen,
aber wirklich Know-how aufbauen
und wirklich tiefgreifend neue Sachen lernen,
machst du eigentlich so gut wie nie auf der Arbeit.
Die 99% der Sachen, die ich gelernt habe,
sind, weil ich mich privat dafür interessiere.
Nach drei Monaten.
Ich auch nicht.
Es muss halt sein, wobei ich muss sagen, doch, doch.
Frontend macht schon in gewisser Weise Spaß,
wenn man sieht, dass im Browser sich was tut.
Ich kann nicht sagen, dass mir das gar keinen Spaß macht.
Was mir definitiv keinen Spaß macht, sind CSS-Design-Geschichten.
Das liegt aber auch daran, dass ich da einfach zu schlecht drin bin.
Es ist nicht, dass ich Frontend nicht genieße,
aber ich mag es nicht, meinen eigenen HTML und CSS zu schreiben.
Es wäre kein Problem, wenn ich den HTML und CSS gegeben hätte
und ich nur Kode drauf hätte.
Aber die Sache bei dieser Plattform und meinem Team
ist, dass es nicht kundesbezüglich ist.
Es ist ein interner Werkzeug, der in der Firma verwendet wird.
Software-Engineer sind wirklich verantwortlich für
ihren eigenen HTML und CSS zu schreiben,
was wirklich schrecklich ist.
Ich kann dir noch was Lustiges von der Arbeit erzählen.
Wir hatten letztens richtig, richtig krasse Probleme,
weil jemand wieder sehr verbesserungswürdig
seinen Job gemacht hat.
Und zwar, es gab ein neues Update.
Also es ist ja bei uns so, wir haben ja relativ viele Leute im Außendienst
und die kriegen Software von uns zur Verfügung gestellt.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht so sehr in Detail beschreiben,
zumindest, es gab ein Update oder mehrere Updates für die Software,
die eben der Außendienst verwendet.
Und man kam auf die glorreiche Idee,
man könnte ja eine neue Java-Version verwenden.
Das Problem dabei ist, wenn du eine neue Java-Version verwendest,
musst du erstmal eine neue runtime runterladen
und jegliche Abhängigkeiten an Libraries und sonstige Sachen,
die du verwendest, werden quasi neu kompiliert gegen die neue Java-Version.
Das heißt, das Update war nicht wie sonst irgendwie 15 MB groß,
sondern irgendwie 500 MB groß.
Obwohl sich technisch gar nicht so viel geändert hat.
Das Problem war nur, dass die Leute Montagmorgen,
als sie angefangen haben zu arbeiten,
haben die natürlich alle erstmal,
also sprich irgendwelche Außendienstleute,
haben gesagt, ich fahre jetzt irgendwo hin,
verkaufe irgendwelchen Leuten was oder ich gucke mal meine Verträge an.
Und die haben ihr Außendienstsystem aufgemacht
und mussten Updates installieren.
Und da haben dann erstmal 1000 Leute gleichzeitig versucht,
500 MB Updates runterzuladen bei uns.
Und das war halt ein bisschen zu viel für unsere Internetanbindung.
Da war dann halt RIP.
Ja, aber wisst ihr was witzig ist,
so typische Entscheidung bei uns ist ja,
erstmal Panik.
Wir haben zwar mittlerweile für alles irgendwelche Workflows,
aber wenn es dann doch so weit ist,
das was kaputt geht, dann trotzdem alle Panik
und scheißen auf Workflows.
Und dann haben sie zig Dinge sich überlegt,
was man machen könnte.
Und was ich witzig fand,
dass sie dann auch auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen sind,
das Sache, die wir beziehungsweise ich auch schon seit,
keine Ahnung, drei Jahren oder so erzählen,
so nach dem Motto, warum lassen wir unsere Softwareupdates
nicht einfach beispielsweise aus Azure
oder Cloudflare oder irgendwo anders ausliefern?
Das wäre ja eigentlich gar kein Problem.
Könnten wir eigentlich machen.
Wollte man bisher aber nie,
haben wir gesagt, ah nee, das geht nicht,
blablabla und so.
Naja, zumindest hatte man das Problem.
So, und dann haben sie panisch im Kreis gelaufen
und haben sich überlegt, was wir machen sollen.
So nach dem Motto, können wir jetzt nicht doch
doch schnell irgendwie eine VM hinstellen,
irgendwie sonst wie oder sonst wo.
Und dann kam die Idee, Leute, das funktioniert alles nicht.
Zumal derjenige, der weiß, wie das Update funktioniert,
auch im Urlaub ist, obwohl wir ja keinerlei Kopfwissen wir haben
bei einzelnen Personen.
Und dann kam richtig BigBrain-Management-Entscheidung.
Wir sitzen jetzt einfach aus.
Also hatten wir irgendwie keine Ahnung.
Drei, vier Tage permanent Fehler und unsere Hotline,
also unsere Support-Hotline ist glaube ich,
ist glaube ich komplett durchgedreht,
weil die drei Tage lang durchgängig bombardiert wurden
mit Leuten, die sich beschwert haben.
Die haben einfach entschieden, wir sitzen jetzt einfach aus.
Easy.
Okay, guck mal, fertig.
Ja, ich auch nicht.
Warum nicht? Meine Antwort ist, warum nicht?
Ich glaube, ich machs einfach in andere Farben.
Oh mein Gott.
BigBrain.
Das stimmt.
Ja.
Da hat er voll und ganz recht.
Das ist wirklich was, das kann ich so auch bei uns,
so hier in der Arbeitsplätze,
kann ich komplett unterschreiben.
Wenn ihr einen guten Chef habt oder einen guten Manager
oder wie auch immer man das nennt,
und ihr sagt ihm entweder irgendwas,
was euch persönlich nicht schmeckt, ja,
was weiß ich, dass ihr irgendwie Probleme habt
mit manchen Leuten zusammenarbeiten,
weil sowieso oder ihr sagt vielleicht was Objektives,
was nicht gut läuft, es reicht, es muss,
also es sollte reichen, wenn ihr das einmal sagt.
Das heißt nicht, dass es dann automatisch passiert,
aber zumindest, zumindest sollte er sich bei euch melden,
ohne dass ihr fünfmal nachfragen müsst.
Also egal, was ihr ihm sagt, es sollte dann,
was weiß ich, zwei, drei Wochen dauern
oder wenn es was Komplizierteres ist,
meinetwegen auch länger, dann sollte er euch sagen,
was rausgekommen ist oder zwischendurch so hier,
ich hab das jetzt da und da weitergegeben,
ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, was da rauskommt,
aber ich hab auf jeden Fall was gemacht.
Also das, das ist wichtig, das ist das,
was bei uns teilweise funktioniert,
also bei meinem Chef klappt das eigentlich ganz gut,
wenn man da was sagt oder auch umgedreht,
deswegen versuche ich mich dann auch immer schnell,
um die Sachen zu kümmern, wenn er was sagt.
Aber auf anderen Ebenen klappt das bei uns überhaupt nicht.
Ich weiß, wir hatten zum Beispiel einen Kollege von mir,
der im anderen Team ist, da oft auf der Arbeit,
der hatte einen Chef, das war so der typische Vertreter von,
ja, da sind wir dran.
Kennt ihr so diese Antwort?
So nach dem Motto, hier wir haben festgestellt,
das Passwort für unsere Testumgebung ist zu einfach,
das muss geändert werden.
Ja, da sind wir dran.
Da sind wir dran.
Da fragst du ein halbes Jahr später,
und wie sieht es aus?
Ah, da sind wir dran.
Das habe ich mitgenommen, da sind wir dran.
Es ist in Klärung, genau, es ist in Klärung.
Also davon gibt es viel zu viele, die diese Taktik fahren.
Das stimmt, aber das ist wirklich so.
Es ist genauso, es ist wirklich sagt, genauso wie er sagt,
wenn ihr einen guten Chef oder einen guten Manager habt,
oder auch, kann man übertragen,
Teamleiter oder was auch immer, Teamleiter, wie auch immer,
das muss reichen, wenn ihr auf ein Problem hinweist,
und dann tut sich was.
Es heißt nicht, dass es automatisch so gemacht wird,
wie ihr das sagt, aber sollte sich was tun,
und ihr solltet davon erfahren, was rausgekommen ist.
Ja, da hat er voll und ganz recht.
Das ist übrigens auch, sorry, ich muss laufen und erbrechen,
aber ich kann mich da echt gut mit identifizieren.
Zum Beispiel, wo man das sieht,
ich habe bei meinem Chef seit einer ganzen Weile schon erzählt,
hier, ich würde gerne ein bisschen mehr Zeug programmieren,
wieder ein bisschen mehr selbst Zeug programmieren,
und das klappt jetzt auch, hat eine Weile gedauert,
und ich habe mir gesagt,
ich würde gerne ein bisschen mehr Zeug programmieren,
wieder ein bisschen mehr selbst Zeug programmieren,
das klappt jetzt auch, hat eine Weile gedauert,
aber das funktioniert jetzt auch,
ich kann jetzt wieder ein bisschen mehr Zeug basteln,
wo ich ja schon die ganze Zeit scharf drauf war,
weil immer nur Code Reviewen ist auch doof.
Und das hat jetzt auch funktioniert,
wir haben jetzt einige Tools am Start,
die es so nicht gegeben hätte, wenn ich die nicht gebaut hätte,
und die hat keiner in dem Sinn irgendwie extern beauftragt,
also das funktioniert schon.
Wenn man an beiden Stellen Personen hat, die das wollen.
Okay, er muss Yes sagen, hat aber keinen Bock.
Genau, man braucht einfach Rückmeldung,
man muss einfach wissen, was Sache ist.
Habe ich euch mal die Story erzählt, wie lange das gedauert hat,
ich glaube das habe ich, ich weiß nicht,
doch habe ich bestimmt schon gemacht,
wie lange das gedauert hat damals,
als ich Teilzeitarbeiten beantragt habe bei uns?
Ich weiß nicht, wie lange das gedauert hat,
ich weiß nicht, wie lange das gedauert hat,
dass ich Teilzeitarbeiten beantragt habe bei uns?
Es war der typische Fall von,
mein damaliger Chef hat es verkackt, aber richtig mega verschissen.
Weiß nicht gar, ob ich es erzählt habe,
es hat ewig gedauert, es hat wirklich ewig gedauert.
Und man hat nie was gehört, die ganze Zeit nicht.
Ich muß ja dann sogar, ich muß ja sogar zum Betriebsrat,
und selbst das hat ewig gedauert.
Ich war aber auch einer der ersten, der das gemacht hat.
Aber warum ist er denn 13 Monate dabeigeblieben?
Wenn er nach 3 Monaten keinen Bock hat.
Was ist denn Lead Coding?
Ist das so eine Übungsseite?
Stocks? Stocks?
Ok, das ist so ein Ami-Ding. Was ist RSU?
Ist das sowas, was du von deinem Gehalt in Aktien bekommst?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Das ist eigentlich eine coole Geschichte.
Das fände ich bei uns auch eine coole Option.
Ja, das frage ich mich auch, warum ist er noch so lange dabeigeblieben?
Also ist es doch Südkorea?
Ja, ich habe mich nicht so lange dabeigeblieben.
Aber seit ich damals auf einem Arbeitsvisal war,
war das Prozess von der Visa-Q,
der Arbeitsverwaltung, etc.
Das hat die ganze Prozesse von 3 Monaten dabeigeblieben.
Ich habe wirklich keine Ahnung davon, was das 5% RSU ist.
Aber weil meine Visa-Aprüfung so lange dauerte,
hatte ich keine Wahl, aber das ganze Jahr an Amazon zu beenden.
Und ich habe das 5%.
Oh.
Ja, ich meine, bei seinen 5% hätte es wahrscheinlich nicht gebracht.
Ich kann nicht alles nachvollziehen.
Klingt echt nach Hand und Fuß, was er erzählt hat.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Muss ich nicht wissen.
Ich werde mich wahrscheinlich nie bei Microsoft bewerben.
Ich werde im Chat gucken, ob ich irgendetwas übersehen habe.
Also Bezahlung in Aktien, das wäre auch teilweise echt bei uns in Deutschland eine coole Option.
Ich glaube, die meisten machen das hier nicht.
Ich würde sagen, wir lassen uns jetzt mal eine Runde von LevelCaptureBaden.
Neues Battlefield 20, sondern die Beta Date liegt.
Ja, nachdem sie den Kram, ich muss mal übrigens kurz in meine Mails gucken,
habe ich schon seit einer Woche immer reingeschaut,
auf dem zweiten Bildschirm.
Nachdem sie jetzt ja den ganzen Kram verschoben haben,
muss natürlich auch Beta und alle möglichen anderen Dinger verschoben werden.
AliExpress hat mir gerade eine Meldung geschickt.
Ihre Bestellung ist angekommen.
Ja, ich weiß, sie ist schon eine Woche da.
Die China-Chinesen, Alter.
Okay, schauen wir uns das mal an.
Lassen wir uns mal eine Runde LevelCaptureBaden.
Sack.
Leaked.
Die PS5, die sieht aus wie dieser Roboter aus WALL-E.
Kennt ihr den?
WALL-E, wie hat man den nochmal geschickt?
WALL-E, Eva oder so hieß die doch, Eve.
Genau, die PS5 sieht original aus wie Eve.
Eva.
WALL-E?
Das finde ich mit der besten Animationsfilm, den es gibt.
Das waren auch die Zeiten, wo sie wirklich richtig gute Filme rausgehauen haben.
WALL-E 2 braucht keiner.
DER NEW OPEN BEDA DATES
DIES IS global community manager
Das da unten, das da unten kann ich weder B noch entstetigen, ja?
Naja, wir dürfen uns ja mal nicht, man darf sich ja nicht der Illusion hingeben, dass es mit irgendwie
keine Ahnung, einem Monat Verschiebung oder so, nee, wieviel haben, keine Ahnung, wieviel wurde jetzt genau verschoben? Ich sag jetzt einfach mal einen Monat,
dass da irgendwelche grundlegenden Sachen sich ändern.
Das ist ja illusorisch, davon auszugehen. Also was jetzt kacke ist, wird auch bei Release kacke sein. Aber ich könnte mir vorstellen,
dass es
auch nicht so schlimm wird, wie das teilweise auf
Reddit oder so gemalt wurde, so nach dem Motto, die Beta war so mega enttäuschend und jetzt wo sie es verschoben haben,
haben sie sich ja eingestanden, dass das ja quasi doch genauso kacke immer noch ist, wie in der Beta oder so. Das glaube ich nicht, das glaube ich nicht.
Also der Beta-Stand, den man da gesehen hat, oder was heißt der Beta-Stand, dieser
Testing Playtest da, wo es ganz viel geleakt gab und so, das war definitiv
Monatelter Bild, da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher, anders kann das auch überhaupt nicht funktionieren.
Und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass man diese, diesen Monat doch jetzt sinnvoll nutzen kann.
Vor allem Sachen zu fixen,
Kleinigkeiten, die halt einfach kaputt sind und den Spielfluss und das Gameplay verunstalten.
Oder aber, was man ja auch machen kann, ist, wenn man jetzt durch das Feedback, durch den Playtest und das, was die Leute geschrieben haben und
gesehen hat, dass man jetzt vielleicht die Auswahl hatte, hey,
nehmen wir Weg A oder nehmen wir Weg B,
aber, wie soll ich das jetzt beschreiben, aber der, sag mal so, Entwicklungstechnisch, nicht viel Unterschied ist.
Also sei es von Fahrzeug
Handling bis zu
irgendwelchen Sachen, wo sie sich noch nicht so ganz sicher waren, nehmen wir das, nehmen wir das, aber
Implementierungs-mäßig ist es gar kein so großer Aufwand.
Oder man kann es relativ schnell umstricken. Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass sie innerhalb von einem Monat ordentlich was machen können
und mal im Ernst, im Prinzip wäre das ja anderweitig auch genauso gelaufen. Das Game wäre rausgekommen und die hätten dann erst mal
einen Day-One-Patch rausgehauen, der riesengroß wäre, und die hätten den nächsten Monat über
noch mal eins, zwei Riesen-Patches rausgehauen. Also im Prinzip kriegen wir das Game jetzt nach
einem Day-One-Patch und eins, zwei großen Patches.
Was jetzt halt nicht unbedingt dafür sorgt, dass wir bei Release keinen Day-One-Patch kriegen, den wird es so oder so geben.
Da können wir uns irgendwie, das ist ja mittlerweile schon, gehört ja zum guten Ton, der Day-One-Patch.
Stört mich nicht.
Mich stört es überhaupt nicht, dass es delayed wurde.
Stört mich überhaupt nicht.
Solange es was taugt ist, also mir ist es lieber, es kommt ein Game raus, gerade Battlefield braucht das jetzt auch mal, wieder ein Game raus, was was taugt, als dass es einen Monat früher kommt.
Weiß nicht, wie es euch geht.
Na ja, das stimmt, das stimmt ja schon, in der Regel ist umso kleiner der Kühler, umso schlechter, aber
das kommt natürlich drauf an, ob das Ding noch nach wie vor so viel
Abwärme produziert, ja.
Wer weiß, was da sonst noch sich geändert hat, vielleicht bessere Platzierungen der Komponenten, vielleicht irgendwie Fertigungsprozess verbessert, keine Ahnung.
Gab es, gab es noch irgendein Triple-A-Game, was in Plane rausgekommen ist, wahrscheinlich, also
Stimmt, stimmt.
Was ich ein bisschen lustig finde, ist, dass es auf Corona schieben.
Das halte ich ja zum Beispiel für bescheuert.
Twitter, Battlefield, ich muss euch mal kurz die offizielle Meldung dazu zeigen.
Das ist natürlich unsinnig.
Sie schreiben hier, sie schreiben hier, dass das Global Pandemic, Unforeseen Challenges, warum haben sie nicht
geschrieben Unforeseen Consequences, da hätten sich zumindest die Half-Life 3 Leaker irgendwie freuen können.
Also das, also das ist, das ist, das halte ich für Schwachsinn.
Das halte ich für Schwachsinn, da jetzt Corona vorzuschieben.
Sie haben Anfang des Jahres, nee Schwachsinn, stimmt gar nicht Anfang des Jahres, im
im Juni oder so haben die noch erzählt.
Sie sind richtig gut dabei und haben schon viel mehr geschafft, als sie eigentlich gedacht haben, blablabla
und da war ja Corona noch voll, voll Effekt.
Das ist, das ist, das ist schwachsinnig.
Das ist auch nichts, was man einen Monat vorher merkt.
Das sieht man ja.
Also wenn die das wirklich erst einen Monat vorher merken, dass es nach Corona nicht so läuft, mit Corona nicht so
läuft, wie sie sich das vorgestellt haben, dann sollte man jegliche Projektleiter und Manager direkt
rausschmeißen, das kann nicht sein.
Also das ist einfach nur vorgeschoben als so 0 nach 15 Grund, den einem die Leute gerade gut abkaufen.
Also mit Corona hat das garantiert nichts zu tun.
Vielleicht hat es, vielleicht resultiert das irgendwie schon ein bisschen da draus.
Aber das ist nichts, was ihnen jetzt erst aufgefallen ist.
Coronavirus, genau.
Es ist ja auch eine gute Begründung zur Zeit.
Wenn irgendwas delayed, kannst du einfach sagen, ja Corona ist schuld.
Corona geht immer aktuell.
New design have been put to rest by Digital Foundry working in collaboration with Gamers Nexus.
The two tech outlets put both the new and old PlayStation five revisions to the test benchmarking them in
various conditions and tearing them apart to do a physical analysis of the changes.
Their findings show no meaningful difference between the two heat sink designs.
If anything, the new design is slightly more efficient because it does a better job of cooling the
PlayStation fives VRMs.
The most recent update for Apex Legends wreaked havoc on the game's matchmaking servers.
Players have been getting disconnected about three times more than normal following multiple
update attempts to fix the issue.
This has prompted widespread outrage over the state of the game.
It's especially bad considering that there's a rank split coming and the disconnects make you lose rank points.
The update launched as a midseason event with new challenges.
Apex juckt mich nicht.
Aber eins muss man sagen, Apex macht extrem viel Asche.
Das ist kein Fortnite, aber es macht extrem viel Asche.
Halo Infinite hat noch keine Forge? Halo 3 hatte schon eine Forge.
Und ich glaub die davor auch.
Halo Infinite ist dieses Weihnachtsjahr eröffnet, aber bis nächstes Jahr wird die französische Custom-Mode- und Map-Engine Forge.
Splitgate bekommt eine Forge-Mode, das klingt wie ein absoluter Sieg für die Spieler.
Die Leute werden wahrscheinlich bessere Maps selbst bauen als die offiziellen.
Esports-Fans haben einige tolle Nachrichten. Valve hat sich überprüft, dass das nächste CSGO-Major in Stockholm vorhanden sein wird.
Es wurde vorhin wegen der Covid-Travels und öffentlichen Fortschritte ausgebildet.
Valve hat sich für ein anderes Host-Land angeschaut, aber Schweden hat sich vorhin mit vielen internationalen Anwesenden für große öffentliche Events entschlossen.
Die Tickets gehen nächste Woche auf Sälen.
Es wird das größte Tournament in CSGOs Geschichte mit einem 2-Million-Dollar-Prize-Pool.
Das Event beginnt im Oktober 2016.
Die Arena öffnet für Live-Matches am 4. November.
Valve hat auch überprüft, dass dieses Jahr's Dota2-International-Event in Rumänien angekommen ist.
Man muss mal sagen, so kleine Nischen-Tournaments bei CS haben mehr Zuschauer als die Overwatch League.
Die müssten sich in Valorant warm anziehen. Da kann man sich darüber streiten.
Es gibt ja kaum Valorant-Events. Also CS ist da deutlich lebendiger als Valorant.
Ich hab nur Geflame gelesen über die Beta.
Hat jemand von euch gespielt? Gibt's die eigentlich auch auf dem PC?
Ich hab nur Negatives gehört über das Game. Und ich verspüre absolut keinerlei Bedarf, mir das Game zu kaufen.
Während das Game nicht genau die gleichen Konkurrent-Player-Count-Nummern wie beim Launchen,
ist es trotzdem sehr gut, dank der Update.
Riot Games haben einen neuen Klient für ihre Games ausgeliefert, den Riot Client.
Wie die meisten Game-Developer-Klienten, werden alle Riot-Titles mit einem einzigen App ausgeliefert.
Es beginnt am 20. September und alle ihre Games werden am 4. Oktober integriert.
Du wirst trotzdem die Launch-Games mit individuellen Abwechslungen auswählen.
Ein erneuerter Bau von Steam-OS hat durch Valve die neuen Steam-Deck-Konsolen ausgeliefert.
Die Steam-Deck-Ui verwendet ein Steam-Deck.
Big Picture-Mode ist ein UI-Design für Steam mit einem Controller auf deinem PC.
Im Dezember ist der UI auf Steam-OS 3, ein Linux-Bild, custom-konfiguriert von Valve,
um ihre Games und Software direkt auszuwählen.
Die UI und der neue Bau von Steam-OS sind immer noch im Prozess,
also gibt es nicht alle Funktionen oder Features.
Das sagt, der Screenshot sieht ziemlich erheblich aus,
und es ist consistent mit dem aktuellen Refresh von Steam-Deck-Konsolen von Valve.
Der 10-jährige MMO Guild Wars 2 bekommt einen bedeutenden Update,
welches DirectX 11-Support gibt. Bis jetzt hat es nur DirectX 9 unterstützt,
um das Spiel zu verhindern.
Das Spiel kostet zwei.
Und obwohl DirectX 11 nicht genau die neue Karte auf dem Block ist,
ist es ein massiver Leak-Forward für das Spiel
und wird den Entwicklern viel mehr Freiheit geben,
die Visualen zu verbessern, ohne sich zu verletzen.
Obwohl es so alt ist, sieht Guild Wars 2 noch ziemlich gut aus,
besonders als andere MMOs.
Es ist schwer zu sagen, ob die Devs in der nächsten Zukunft
mit DirectX 11 unterstützt werden,
aber DirectX 11-Support öffnet die Türen für weitere Verbesserungen,
die sie mit DirectX 9 nie erzielen können.
Bevor wir die letzte neue Geschichte der Woche begleiten,
lasst mich in den Kommentaren wissen,
was Sie für die verrückten News dieser Woche gedacht haben.
Für mich persönlich war es natürlich der Battlefield 2042 Delay.
Ich habe nur die Beta gespielt, das hat mir nicht gefallen,
aber mittlerweile muss es ein komplett anderes Game sein,
kann ich nichts zu sagen zu Elder Scrolls Online.
Das Einzige, was mich davon abhält, Elder Scrolls Online auszuprobieren,
ist, dass es wohl erstens easy as fuck sein muss
und zweitens mehr oder weniger ein Singleplayer-MMO.
Sogar vor dem Produktionsschedule,
mussten sie das Spiel belästigen.
Halo-Komponist Marty O'Donnell
wurde in der Unverfassungsgabe von Destiny's Music
im Kontext der Kurse gefunden.
O'Donnell wurde von Bungie in 2014 gefeiert,
bevor Destiny 1 eröffnete.
Er hat Bungie im folgenden Jahr gefeiert
und gewonnen, dass Bungie übersteppt hat,
in seinem kreativen Prozess zu kontrollieren.
Das war ein großer Deal,
denn O'Donnell ist Co-Founder des Studios
und wurde gefeiert,
dass Bungie seine Steuern von der Firma eröffnen würde.
Der Ruhling hat ihm eine Menge seiner Stockoptionen als Geld gewonnen,
aber es kam mit der Stipulation,
dass O'Donnell die Rechte zu den Komponisten,
die er für Destiny eröffnete, eröffnen musste.
Die Dinge gingen auf der anderen Seite,
von 2019 an, als O'Donnell
von seiner Arbeit auf Destiny
via YouTube und Musik-Retailer Bandcamp veröffentlicht hat.
Bungie hat ihn gebeten,
die Musik abzulegen und fast 100.000 Dollar
für das Saufen zu bezahlen.
Das war's für diese Woche im Gaming.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen
und bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass euch das Video gefallen hat.
Wenn ihr mehr von uns sehen wollt,
könnt ihr uns gerne abonnieren.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder.
Tschüss!
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschüss!
Reaktieren zu kontroversierten Software-Opinionen.
Das stimmt nicht.
Das sind die Gefühle, die ihr auch kennt.
Nein!
In diesem Video schauen wir uns an,
die kontroversierten Software-Opinionen,
auf Stack Overflow.
Das ist bekannt für...
Stack Overflow Service 2021.
Das müssen wir uns auch noch angucken.
Einfach mal ganz im Ernst.
Objektorientierung ist überhaupt nichts Schlimmes.
Da muss ich einfach nur überlegen...
Eigentlich ist es sogar...
Das finde ich eine recht sinnvolle Geschichte.
Da muss ich halt nur überlegen,
dass man es nicht übertreibt.
Ich muss nicht alles irgendwie in
Manager und Factories
und Klassen und Dingster kapseln.
Also ich brauche nicht eine...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich habe letztens ein Video gesehen,
der hat gezeigt, wie er ASP.NET Core-Controller
programmiert und hat gesagt,
jeder Controller mit mehr als 3-4 Zeilen
Code drinne ist quasi...
nicht lesbar und nicht...
solid und nicht objektorientiert genug.
Was auch immer.
Das mag ja alles
auf dem Papier schön und gut sein.
Aber man muss das immer abwägen.
Also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
ein bisschen mehr Logik
an der einen Stelle brauche
oder ob ich jetzt
die Hälfte meiner Architektur
überdenken muss, weil ich noch irgendwelche
Zwischenschichten einziehen muss,
da schreibe ich halt 5-6 Zeilen mehr.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Genauso wie ich auch die ganze Geschichte
nicht verstehe, was die Leute gegen
kleine UI-Anwendungen,
sowas, was man heutzutage eigentlich nicht mal macht,
weil man heute irgendwelche Browser-Geschichten macht,
aber irgendwelche kleinen lokalen UI-Geschichten,
sei es WPF, Windows Forms oder
oder meinetwegen auch WPF,
ich weiß gar nicht, was die Leute gegen
Code-Behind-Dateien haben.
Wenn es irgendwas ist
mit zwei GUI-Forms oder einer GUI-Form
und ein paar Inputs oder
irgendwie eine Anzeige... Warum keine
Code-Behind-Dateien? Wozu?
Was ist das Problem? Was ist das Problem,
was die Leute mit Code-Behind-Dateien haben,
wenn es um kleine Sachen geht?
Was für Dateien?
Moment.
Code-Behind-Dateien sind,
wenn du beispielsweise... Ups.
Code-Behind-Dateien
sind, wenn du
in Windows Forms
Anwendung anlegst
und deinen Code
in die gleiche Datei schreibst,
wo auch dein
GUI-Code mit drinne ist.
Also wenn du das
über den Assistent in
Visual Studio machst, dann sagst du hinzufügen,
neues Form.
Normalerweise ist in diese Datei
plus die Logik für die Forms
oder auch bei WPF.
Man kann natürlich
in diese Datei,
wo die Logik für das GUI drin ist oder das
Designer-Zeug, kann man quasi
in dieses Datei reingehen
und da noch zusätzliche Sachen reinschreiben.
Das ist dann quasi Code-Behind-Datei.
Das ist total verpönt,
ich verstehe nicht warum, wenn es für kleine
Sachen ist, warum nicht?
Man muss es nicht übertreiben.
Genauso wie man auch nicht für irgendwelche
kleinen Webseiten, irgendwelche
CI, CD,
Geschichten,
Workflows und
Kubernetes-Cluster und haste nicht gesehen
braucht. Man muss es
für kleine Sachen einfach nicht übertreiben.
Genau, genau.
Es ist wichtig, dass man sich überlegt,
was braucht man, was ist sinnvoll für das
jeweilige Problem, wie kann man das am besten lösen,
was ist die beste Technik dafür
und natürlich auch wenn es dann mal größer wird,
dass man das dann irgendwie ordentlich machen kann.
Aber nachdem wir eh alle keinerlei Kommentare
in Codes schreiben, weil unser Code
ja so aussagekräftig ist, dass man keine Kommentare
machen kann, aber auch haben wir auch das Problem,
alle nicht. So, gucken wir uns mal an.
Was gibt es jetzt? Neues.
Übrigens, weil ich es gerade im Chat sehe,
muss ich jetzt gerade noch eine kleine
Geschichte erzählen.
Kein Kubernetes-Cluster für die
Schulwebseite mit 100 Aufrufen. Ich kann mich
noch dran erinnern, wir hatten mal,
ich bin mir leider nicht mehr ganz
sicher über die Aufrufe, aber wir hatten
mal ein Meeting, ist schon ein paar Jahre her,
da kamen irgendwelche Leute und haben gesagt,
wir haben hier eine neue Web-Applikation am Start
und dafür brauchen wir einen richtig
fetten Server. Was ist denn so das
fetteste, was ihr noch irgendwie
besorgen könnt? Und ich so, na gut,
müssten wir mal beim Rechenzentrumsbetrieb
Leute fragen, was die haben, aber ich denke
mal, das fetteste
ist wahrscheinlich irgendwas, keine Ahnung,
zwei Terabyte RAM und
64 Kerne und hast du nicht
gesehen, also wir haben schon
ordentlich fette Kisten, aber bevor
wir so weit gehen,
von was reden wir denn hier überhaupt? Also
was ist das? Ja, Web-Anwendung für den
Außendienst und braucht richtig
fett, braucht richtig fett Performance,
die haben schon ordentlich Aufrufe, die haben richtig viele
Aufrufe. Da habe ich
gedacht, okay,
über wie viele Aufrufe reden wir hier denn?
Ja, und dann
hatte er, ich weiß leider die Zahl nicht mehr,
deswegen muss ich das jetzt ein bisschen improvisieren.
Dann meinte er so, 1000!
Dann sag ich so, oh, 1000, ja 1000,
1000 in was? Am Tag!
Hahaha
Moment, langsam
Ich weiß nicht, Leute,
es kann auch sein, dass er 10.000 gesagt hat,
ich weiß es nicht mehr. Es war zumindest
am Tag und es war lächerlich,
es war lächerlich.
Wo wir dann
dabei sind,
nur weil irgendjemand meint,
dass er das braucht, heißt es noch lange nicht,
dass er das wirklich braucht.
Hahaha
Das ist 10.000 am Tag gewesen sein,
das ist eigentlich vollkommen egal.
Es war nichts, es war wirklich
nichts.
Oh Mann.
Okay, jetzt, jetzt
controversial opinions.
Ich hab gar keinen Rep on Stack Overflow,
ich hab nicht mal einen Stack Overflow Account.
Nö, finde ich, finde ich überhaupt nicht.
Ich finde überhaupt nicht,
dass das zackt.
Gar nicht.
Man muss immer nur, man muss einfach
automatisch an die Sache rangehen und gucken,
okay, was ist das Problem,
was ich hier hab, wie kann ich das am besten lösen.
Und ich finde, dass das
ist überhaupt gar kein Problem.
Zumal, und das ist jetzt, das ist jetzt ja auch eine
ganz coole Geschichte,
zumal, wenn man sich mal Sprachen
anguckt, wie es hier schafft zum Beispiel,
die ja als rein
objektorientierte
Sprache gestartet sind.
Ich meine vielleicht nicht so krass wie Ruby,
Ruby ist ja quasi somit das objektorientierteste,
was du machen kannst.
Aber selbst Ruby hat
mittlerweile viele funktionale Sachen und sie schabt
auch. Also
es ist mittlerweile eher so der Trend
dahin, dass die
Sprachen so eher
multi-paradigmen
mäßig sind. Du kannst dann Sachen
objektorientiert machen, du kannst auch einige Sachen
funktional angehaucht machen.
Prozedural natürlich sowieso.
Ja. So.
Ist das nicht, ist das nicht der Typ?
Ist das nicht der OSPF Typ?
Also das,
was sie in OSPF benutzen,
zum Wege finden.
Das hat schon,
Leute, ich muss sagen, das hat schon
durchaus seinen Sinn, dass man Sachen
vererben kann und wiederverwenden kann.
Also gerade in Go, die ja sowas
gar nicht haben, ist es teilweise echt
ätzend, wenn du Sachen drei und viermal
machen musst.
Wobei doch ein bisschen geht's in Go.
Also das hat, das hat alles seine
Daseinsberechtigung.
Und gerade Interface
ist die beste Erfindung.
Ja, das stimmt schon.
Das stimmt schon. Also ein bisschen
mehr Boilerplate ist da.
Aber gerade
was dort netten Sie scharp angeht, ist Microsoft
da ganz hart dabei, das zu reduzieren.
Man darf sie nicht vergessen, dass in
.NET 6, jetzt schon,
seit.NET 5, ist ein
Minimal-C-Sharp-Programm
quasi genauso lang wie
ein Minimal-Python-Programm.
Also eine Zeile.
Nichts mehr mit Public-Static-Main-Args-Gedöns.
Ja,
im Spell kannst du alles knicken.
Warum findest du Interfaces
gut? Weil du mit Interfaces
vermeiden kannst, dass du Sachen
miteinander
verknotest, die man nicht
miteinander verknoten sollte.
Deswegen sind Interfaces ganz praktisch.
Beispiel.
Boah,
okay.
Keine Ahnung. Du nimmst,
du hast irgendwas, was
eine Connection,
irgendeine Netzwerk-
Connection managt. Und
darüber willst du verschiedene
Sachen ausführen. Das heißt, du hast
irgendeine Klasse Base-Command
oder irgendwie sowas,
wo dann drin steht die Information,
was du ausführen willst. Und du hast eine
Klasse, die quasi, die
deine Netzwerkverbindung
managt für die
eigentliche Datenübertragung. So.
Und jetzt ist halt die Frage, muss
deine
Command-Klasse, die Netzwerk-
Management-Klasse kennen
und umgedreht?
Das ist ja in der Regel keine gute Idee,
wenn du sagst, hey, Klasse A
kennt Klasse B, aber Klasse B kennt auch
Klasse A. Das kann man machen.
Das ist gar kein Problem,
wenn das auch zwei
Dinge sind, die zusammengehören. Aber
oftmals ist es tatsächlich besser,
man übergibt weder Klasse A direkt
an Klasse B, noch
parent-Klasse
zurück an A,
sondern man macht einfach einen Interface,
was quasi so die Essenz
der Funktion, die du haben willst,
ja,
vorgibt, so nach dem Motto,
ich bin ein Parser, ich bin ein,
ich bin eine Netzwerk-Connection,
ich bin ein Command.
Und da musst du die Klasse gar nicht mehr
übergeben, sondern einfach nur noch das Interface.
Und der weitere
Vorteil davon ist, dass du mit
Interfaces viel mehr
mit Generics anstellen kannst
in C-Sharp als beispielsweise mit Klassen.
Aber ich gebe zu,
dass man
gerade am Anfang
gar nicht so sehr sich mit Interfaces
beschäftigen muss.
Ja, also, ja, mir fällt
jetzt leider gar kein wirklich gutes,
richtig griffiges Beispiel ein.
Müssen wir mal gucken, wenn wir wieder was basteln.
Es fällt mir
jetzt wirklich kein richtig griffiges
Beispiel dazu ein.
Müssen wir mal Gedanken zumachen.
Okay, jetzt lass das mal ins Video durchkommen, kann ich alle
5 Sekunden Stopp drücken.
Ja, das ist auch so.
Ja, ich sehe überhaupt kein Problem drin.
Deswegen,
deswegen ist ja das Gute
und auch das, was man
in den heutigen, zumindest meist,
doch recht verbreitensprachend sieht,
dass du da mehrere Sachen machst.
Also,
wenn du ein
Interfaces-Programm
oder ein
oder ein Interface-Programm
siehst, dass du da mehrere Sachen machen kannst.
Du kannst,
Rust ist relativ funktional
oder Go ist auch relativ funktional,
aber es hat trotzdem ein bisschen
was objektorientiertes dabei ist. Die Sharp
ist rein als objektorientiertes gestartet, Ruby
auch, hat heute aber
einige funktionale Elemente.
Also, muss man
sagen, das ist eigentlich die beste, die beste
Variante, wenn du
das verwenden kannst, was halt
für die jeweilige Situation am besten ist.
Ja,
sehe ich so.
Ich denke, dass das wirklich so ist.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist so.
Ne, ich glaube, das ist so.
Ne, da habe ich auch nichts dagegen.
Da sage ich, ich habe damit,
ich sage nicht, dass das jemand machen muss.
Ja, das ist gar nicht die Frage.
Ich sage nicht, dass man die Leute
dazu zwingen sollte, das privat zu machen,
wenn sie keinen Bock drauf haben, ist das okay.
Ja.
Aber, äh,
wenn du Leute hast, die sich in ihrer Freizeit
mit dann wirklich den
interessanten Dingen, die sie persönlich interessiert,
auch beschäftigt,
nur dann entwickelst du dich irgendwie auch weiter.
Wenn du den ganzen Tag
die 23.
Factory Connection Manager
class programmierst, dann vielleicht nicht.
Und selbst Fortbildungen auf der Arbeit
ersetzen das nicht. Fortbildungen sind in der Regel
PowerPoint-Geschwätz.
Ja, mit ein bisschen
Fingerübungen zwischendurch.
Richtig lernen tust du Sachen, wenn du
persönlich daran interessiert bist
und dich tief in das Problem
einarbeitest, um es zu verstehen.
Und dann am Ende auch rausgehst und sagst, okay,
jetzt verstehe ich auch, warum
die das in Software A
so und so gemacht haben, weil man es mal
selbst versucht hat zu implementieren. Und deswegen,
wenn man da drauf gekommen ist, aha, ist ja eigentlich
ganz logisch. Zum Beispiel,
zum Beispiel. Ich habe mich
immer gefragt, warum
haben Suchmaschinen so ein Problem
mit Wildcards am Anfang?
Also sprich, warum
kann man in Suchmaschinen oftmals
Qt-Chat
suchen, aber
nur ziemlich
schwer Qt-Chat.
So, mit Wildcards.
Das habe ich mich eine ganze, eine ganze Weile
gefragt. Also sprich, warum ist das hier,
warum ist das hier
okay und warum ist das
hier schlecht?
Das habe
ich nie kapiert, bis ich mal selbst versucht
habe, so minimal eine Suchmaschine zu
programmieren. Und dann ist mir das relativ
schnell eingeleuchtet, warum das so ist, warum das Ganze
nicht funktioniert. Suchmaschinen sind
in der Regel, zumindest der
Einstieg in diesen Baum,
aber es ist kein Baum, das stimmt nicht.
Zumindest der
Einstieg in diese,
in den Index aus
Postings und
Positions und so was,
Index ist das richtige Wort. Der
Einstieg in den Index ist
eine sortierte
Liste. Das heißt, alle Suchbegriffe,
die man hat, sind
alphabetisch geordnet. Also
sprich, Google hat intern einen
Index über alle Suchbegriffe
und
die ist alphabetisch
geordnet. Das heißt,
die Begriffe mit a
kommen am Anfang. Also
so, nacheinander
und
davor kommen wahrscheinlich Zahlen
oder was auch immer.
Und
deswegen ist es so schwierig, Wildcards
am Anfang zu machen.
Also keine Ahnung.
Das Wort
ABC
Alpha
oder was auch immer, kommt vor
Bravo, kommt vor
Butter und was auch
immer, wobei das stimmt nicht, das kommt
danach.
Also das ist Alpha
Zulul, kommt
zum Schluss. Also das ist
Suchbegriffe sind
aufsteigend
geordnet. Das ist eine
sortierte Liste.
Und
wenn ich jetzt in Wild, und wie das jetzt,
wie eine Suche funktioniert, ist
erstmal, du nimmst den ersten
Buchstaben von einem Suchbegriff
und guckst, wo geht's
los. Und damit
du das Ganze machen kannst, machst du das mit einer
Binary Search. Binary Search
ist quasi immer die Hälfte, immer die Hälfte.
Nach dem Motto, ich gehe in die Mitte der Liste,
guck, ist das, was ich suche,
größer oder kleiner? Also ich suche jetzt hier beispielsweise
das Wort, was mit C anfängt. Das größer oder
kleiner? Okay, größer. Also nehme ich die
nächste Hälfte, guck, ist es größer oder kleiner?
Und dann bleibt mir noch das eine übrig.
Das heißt, ich weiß, in dem Fall, ich hab's nicht
gefunden. Beziehungsweise
ich bin dann
relativ schnell an der Position, wo ich's
finde, die
Einträge hier zu meinem Suchbegriff.
Und wenn ich einen Wildcard am
Anfang habe, dann
funktioniert das nicht. Wenn ich
einen Wildcard am Anfang von meinem Suchbegriff
habe, dann kann ich nicht durch meine Liste
durchgehen, weil ich nicht Binary Search
mal machen kann. Das heißt, ich muss damit
Wildcards am Anfang funktionieren,
linear durch die ganze Liste meiner
Suchbegriffe suchen.
Und deswegen,
das sind so Sachen, die kapiert man nur,
wenn man sich damit auseinandersetzt, warum
manche Sachen eben
so sind. Weil du es mal
selbst programmiert hast. Wie gesagt, ich hab's nie
verstanden.
Aber
jetzt schon, weil ich es mal selbst
probiert hab.
Ein zweiter umgedrehter
Index alleine bringt dir ja auch nichts.
Das bringt dir nur was,
dann kannst du es vielleicht halbieren.
Weil du dann von oben in
einem Thread und vom unteren im anderen Thread
oder wie auch immer anfangen kannst zu suchen.
Aber du bist auf jeden Fall langsamer.
Also wenn du eine lange Liste
hast und dein Suchbegriff ist irgendwo
in der Mitte, ob du jetzt zwei Listen
linear durchsuchen musst oder eine,
ja, das macht's dann
je nachdem, das macht's dann schon schneller.
Aber weitem nicht so schnell wie so.
Oder was meinste?
Ach so, bei der zweiten
Datenbank ist das letzte Zeichen das erste.
Ja gut, das
kann man auch machen. Also wie gesagt,
es gibt natürlich da Lösungen dafür,
was man so treiben kann.
Aber das
ist erstmal so grundsätzlich die Erklärung,
warum es mit Wildcards am Anfang
schlechter funktioniert.
Gut, das ist wohl
wahr.
Aber Leute, die einfach nur gut
schwätzen können und eigentlich
den Job nicht können, brauchst du auch nicht.
Es ist gut, wenn
die Leute sozial verträglich sind.
Natürlich.
Ich hab auch keinen Bock mit irgendwelchen Idioten zusammen
zu arbeiten. Und es ist auch gut, wenn man
halbwegs normal mit den Leuten reden kann.
Ja, alles keine Frage. Und wenn die das halbwegs normal
erklären können, was sie gemacht haben, also alles kein Ding.
Aber du brauchst keinen Programmierer,
der 90% labern kann und 10%
programmieren. Das ist
unsinnig.
Aber Programmierer ja eh das falsche Wort in der heutigen Zeit
ist. Wir sind ja
heute alle
Fullstack bis
Devops.
Das stimmt.
Das ist auch so. Bin ich
der festen Überzeugung.
Das ist so.
Ja.
So Glück.
Man
könnte auch sagen
gründlich.
Man könnte auch sagen gründlich.
Also ich versuche, ich bin
mega, ihr kennt mich.
Ich bin mega faul. Alles.
Ich mach
eigentlich nichts
wirklich gerne aus eigenem Antrieb, wenn es
Arbeit bedeutet. Aber wenn ich was
mache,
dann will ich, dass mich
nie wieder jemand damit nervt.
Und dementsprechend
versuche ich das dann auch insofern
in die Zukunft zu denken, was könnte
denn alles passieren, dass ich den
Scheiß einmal machen muss und nie wieder.
Das Bild mit der Kugel
ist doof. Warum? Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Ja gut.
Das ist tatsächlich ein doofes
Bild. Das stimmt. Weil
das und das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche
Dinge. Wenn
derjenige, der hier am Ende sitzt,
hier so einen
Quader da bestellt hat,
oder einen Würfel bestellt hat,
dann will er auch einen Würfel haben und keine Kugel.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen,
wenn die daraus irgendwas bauen wollen oder sonst
was, hat er hier natürlich viel weniger dran
als da. Also da kann man
sich jetzt drüber streiten. Aber klar, was
es damit sagen will, ist logisch. Aber
da kann man sich drüber streiten, ob das Bild wirklich
eine gute Aussagekraft hat.
Der Pyramide bauen geht
damit zum Beispiel nicht, selbst wenn er als erstes da
ist.
Das habe ich
laufen.
Ja, also
ich finde, so sollte man das machen.
Nee, nee, Moment mal.
Das ist falsch.
Wir sollten das NPM
Package verwenden.
Ist odd, ist even.
Einfach NPM install, ist odd.
Da bin ich immer am Start.
Ich bin da jeden Tag.
Ich schreibe nicht immer was, aber ich bin da jeden Tag.
Ich gucke, dass da nicht Leute wieder irgendwelche komischen, äh...
Rule...
Was ist das? Rule 34? Bilder posten oder sowas?
...
Wo ist eigentlich der Sebarro?
Natürlich... Natürlich ist Google okay.
Google ist nicht nur okay.
Google ist das wichtigste, was man können muss.
Mein Arzt hat mir gesagt, Google online macht mich kein Arzt.
Das hat nicht viel Sinn für mich, weil...
...
Da kann man sich jetzt wirklich drüber streiten.
Also, es kommt drauf an, was du machst.
Also, ich würde nicht pauschal sagen, es ist Schwachsinn oder es ist richtig.
Wenn du... Also, je nachdem, was du machst.
Wenn du jetzt irgendwelche...
...
Also, wenn du so Sachen machst, dann, glaube ich,
ist wahrscheinlich mehr Praxiserfahrung wichtiger.
Wenn du aber ein bisschen, soll ich sagen,
grundlegendere...
...
out there today say that you don't need a degree to be successful as a programmer.
Du brauchst es auch nicht. Du brauchst es nicht, aber das kann durchaus in gewissen
Bereichen Vorteile haben. Klar. Wohingegen in anderen Bereichen Praxiserfahrung deutlich
wichtiger ist. Das kann man so pauschal wieder Ja noch Nein sagen.
Everything is available basically for free. You can learn anything you want for free.
Wenn das Elon Musk sagt, dann muss es ja stimmen.
And many big companies have dropped their degree requirements for developers altogether. Personally,
I don't have a computer science degree. Everything I've learned has been self-taught or learned on the job.
And I've met many other developers making big salaries without a degree.
So you definitely don't need a degree to break into the industry.
But that being said, if I could go back in time, I would probably pursue a computer science degree.
It can definitely fast track you by getting you internships at big companies.
And I do think that foundation of knowledge would likely make you a better programmer.
But on the other hand, is it really worth four years of your time and one hundred
thousand dollars in student debt?
College definitely isn't a path for everybody. And one of my favorite things about the tech
industry is that you can be successful without a degree, which is a good segway into the next
opinion. There's an awful lot of bad teaching out there, whether you have a degree or not.
You'll eventually find yourself on YouTube trying to learn from.
Ja, ja. Also es gibt es gibt es gibt online viel Schwachsinn.
Es gibt sehr viel Schwachsinn.
Das ist aber wie bei allem das 80 90 Prozent der Sachen sackt.
Und man muss einfach das Gute das Gute finden.
Das kannst du übertragen von Handwerker auf Ärzte auf Programmierer.
80 90 Prozent sind kacke.
Du musst die guten Leute finden.
Das finde ich auch nicht gut.
Das ist das gleiche, wie ich vorhin gesagt habe, so nach dem Motto Niemals Code-Behind-Dateien
verwenden und so was.
Warum nicht?
Ja, es gibt durchaus Anwendungsszenarien, die meisten sogar.
Die meisten bauen keine super komplexe Business Gui Geschichten, sondern irgendwas kleines.
Warum nicht?
Es gibt sogar jetzt, jetzt kommt jetzt kommt eine kontroverse Meinung.
Ja, ich wollte es auch gerade sagen.
Der Chat sagt schon, ich bin sogar der Meinung, man kann Go to verwenden und es ist gar nicht
mal schlecht in den passenden Situationen.
Selbst Go to hat seine Daseinsberechtigung.
Man muss seine Sache nicht zu kleistern mit Go tos.
Das sage ich nicht, aber selbst Go to kann an der richtigen Stelle angewendet durchaus
sinnvoll sein.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie drei Nested Schleifen habe und habe in der inneren
Schleife irgendeine Bedingung, dass ich aus allen raus will.
Das ist zum Beispiel genauso was hier in der Richtung.
Das ist zum Beispiel sinnvolle Geschichte.
Da kann man das verwenden und dann zu sagen, nein, ich mache lieber zig Ifs und Breaks
und sonst was.
Warum?
Ja, nur weil irgendwie der Oberguru gesagt hat, Go to ist immer schlecht, ist doch schwachsinnig.
Was übrigens Sokrates niemals überliefert gesagt hat, ich glaube ihm wird das ja zugeschrieben.
Also unsere Software ist prinzipiell, braucht keine Kommentare und keine Tests, weil wir
programmieren so, dass es für sich selbst steht und dementsprechend ist es auch für
jeden verständlich und hat keine Bugs, deswegen braucht man dafür auch keine Tests, ist ganz
einfach.
Was meint ihr denn, wie viel Zeit man spart mit Self-Documented Code, der einfach immer
perfekt funktioniert?
Man braucht keine Tests, man braucht keine Unit Tests, man braucht keine Tests am Ende
irgendwie ob es funktioniert oder was auch sonst was, nein, man programmiert einfach
und es ist instant fertig und man kann es ausliefern, einfach keine Fehler machen, das
ist ganz einfach.
Das Memboard hat keine Bugs, nee, es hat überhaupt keine Bugs, es hat nur Features, das ist alles
gewollt.
Also meine Meinung dazu, natürlich sind Tests sinnvoll, aber nicht nur Tests um Tests zu
haben, also wenn ich eh nur das teste, lasst mal überlegen, wie sage ich das jetzt am
besten?
Also ich muss das testen, was kaputt gehen kann, ich muss nicht testen, ob die Implementierung
von C Sharp 1 gleich gleich 1 funktioniert oder solche Geschichten und ich brauche auch
nicht den gleichen Test 3 mal nur mit anderer Beschreibung oder, wie soll ich das sagen,
also an sinnvollen Stellen, eventuell auch da wo vielleicht schon öfters mal was kaputt
gegangen ist.
Das ist genauso, das ist ein bisschen ähnlich wie mit Kommentaren, das ist ähnlich wie
mit Comments.
Also ich brauche ja auch keinen, ja, okay, Windows, what the fuck, warum ist das broken?
Okay, es ist, alter Windows, Visual Studio, was passiert wenn ich da jetzt enter, aha,
funktioniert, funktioniert, tut es anscheinend noch, okay, dann machen wir den Klingelchat
mal.
Was natürlich sinnlos ist, was natürlich sinnlos ist, ist wenn ich hier sowas mache,
if, hallo Visual Studio, if, keine Ahnung, was weiß ich, true gleich gleich 1 oder sowas,
es ist egal ob das geht und ich dann einen Kommentar drüber schreibe, checks if true
is equal 1, ne, das ist bescheuert, das ist komplett, komplett bescheuert, also das braucht
kein Mensch als Kommentare, das machen gerne, das machen Leute gerne, die quasi das in
der Schule lernen und wenn der Lehrer dann sagt so nach dem Motto, für jede Zeile, mindestens
eine Zeile Comments oder sowas oder nehmen wir mal was hier, guck mal, hier habe ich
irgendwas gebastelt, es hat zum Beispiel absolut keinen Sinn, wenn ich hier drüber schreibe,
Prince Result oder sowas, das sehe ich, das muss ich da drüber schreiben, ich meine jemand,
der das hier sieht, meint ihr erst, dem ist nicht klar, dass das das Result ausgibt, das
ist, das ist genau so oder wenn ich hier, initiate new call oder so, das ist komplett
sinnvoll oder wenn ich hier drüber schreibe, wait for, ok, wenn ich, wenn ich das hier
hinschreibe, wait for 2,5 seconds, das hat sogar in gewisser Weise noch einen Mehrwert
für alle, die zu blöd sind, 2500 Millisekunden in 2,5 Sekunden umzurechnen.
So, ja, jetzt machen wir mal ein Beispiel, jetzt machen wir mal, jetzt machen wir mal
ein Beispiel, wo ein Kommentar eventuell sinnvoll wäre, zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel hier, ich
habe ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt, ich weiß auch nicht, ich weiß auch
nicht, was ich gerade, also ein sinnloser Kommentar ist sowas, was weiß ich, except from any source
oder so, das wäre jetzt bescheuert, das kann ich sehen, aber wenn ich da beispielsweise
hinschreibe, warum, ja, wenn ich da zum Beispiel irgendwie sowas hinschreiben würde wie,
we need to accept connections from was weiß ich, Azure, blablabla, aus irgendwelchen
Gründen, wir gehen mal davon aus, es hätte damit was zu tun, ja, das nochmal hervorzuheben,
warum man das macht, wenn man das normalerweise nicht macht, warum man beispielsweise sagt,
wir müssen connections von überall accepten, das ist klar, aber warum, weil wir Verbindungen
von außen, keine Ahnung, von irgendeinem Azure Service bekommen, dann finde ich das
durchaus sinnvoll, dass wir das hinzuschreiben, ja, bei Tests ist es im Prinzip ähnlich,
so, weiter, ja, das ist übrigens auch was, was war denn das, oh, ich werde gehostet,
Tests, -> Comments, was wollte ich denn jetzt gerade losweren, ja also, man sollte halt
reinschreiben dort, wo es nicht offensichtlich ist. Dann macht es mit Comments Sinn und
mit Tests ist es ähnlich. Ach genau, Change my requirements. Ja, das ist übrigens auch
was, wo ich persönlich nicht allzu viel von halte. Das ist auch kontroverse Meinung,
gebe ich zu. Es gibt ja so den Ansatz, bevor man auch nur eine Zeile programmiert, programmiert
man die Tests dafür. Ich bin der Meinung, das funktioniert nicht. Vielleicht habt ihr
irgendwelche Gegenbeispiele, wo ihr sagt, jawoll, das klappt wunderbar. Ich glaube,
die Wahrheit liegt irgendwo dazwischen. Es ist sicherlich nicht verkehrt, eine Vorstellung
davon zu haben, was man machen muss im Vorfeld oder eventuell auch schon für die wichtigsten
Sachen ein paar Tests zu passen. Aber zu sagen, bevor ich nicht für alles in Tests habe, fange
ich nicht an zu programmieren, ist praktisch nicht umsetzbar. Ja, und übrigens Tests,
das muss ich jetzt an der Stelle vielleicht auch noch was sagen, Tests, die ich auch nicht
gut finde, sind Tests, die man jedes Mal anpassen muss, wenn es einen Fehler gibt. Also
zum Beispiel man testet den Return Wert von irgendwas. Jedes Mal, wenn ich dort irgendwas
dran ändere, passe ich auch automatisch meinen Test an, dass der Test wieder grün ist. Das
ist nicht Sinn und Zweck von Tests. Die Tests sollen was testen, wo mir klar ist, dass das
so sein muss. Wenn ich jedes Mal immer Code plus Tests anpassen muss, sollte man sich
vielleicht überlegen, ob der Test nicht überflüssig ist. Weil wo ist der Sinn? Weil wo ist der
Sinn von, wenn ich mit jeder Code-Änderung eine Test-Änderung brauche, dass der Test
wieder grün wird? Naja, so, wollen wir mal weiter. Controversial Opinions. Ja, ich gebe
mich zu, ich mag auch keine Tests. Wenn man eine Pasa programmiert, kann es zu viele Kommentare
geben, das kommt auf deinen Pasa an und wie offensichtlich die Sachen sind. Also wenn
du zum Beispiel irgendwas, wenn du zum Beispiel irgendwo eine Liste anlegst, um da irgendwelche
Tokens reinzuschreiben, da musst du nicht darüber schreiben, hier Instantiate New List
oder irgendwie sowas. Das ist natürlich Blödsinn. Wenn du allerdings explizit hervorheben möchtest,
dass dein Pasa an manchen Stellen dafür quasi einen neuen Speicher allokieren muss, wenn
du denkst, hey, das muss ich aus irgendwelchen Gründen performenstechnisch, will ich das
hervorheben, dann schreib es rein. Das muss ja derjenige, der das programmiert, wissen.
Es gibt da eh kaum was Einheitliches. Wenn du mich fragst, ich sag so, wenn du den anderen
fragst, dann sieht es ein bisschen anders. Deswegen ist auch ganz wichtig, finde ich,
was er hier am Anfang gesagt hat. Es hat keinen Sinn, wenn euch irgendjemand erzählt,
es muss immer so sein oder es darf nie so sein oder es darf nie GoTo verwenden zum Beispiel
oder nie Code-Behind-Dateien. Das finde ich ziemlich unsinnig. Einfach das was angemessen
ist. Ja, Moment, Moment, das ist ja auch komplett was anderes. Wenn du schon was hast, ja, sind
wir dann hier. Wenn du schon was hast, was quasi irgendeine fette Anwendung mit was weiß
ich 250.000 Zeilen, die komplex als Fak ist und eh schon kaum noch einer durchblickt.
Klar, dass du da eine Reihe von Tests hast, die das abklopft, das sage ich aber nichts
dagegen. Was ich gemeint habe, ist diese Geschichte mit, du fängst erst gar nicht an zu programmieren,
bevor du nicht irgendwie Tests für alle Fälle hast. Das kann nicht funktionieren. Das klappt
es. Ich habe nirgendwo. Ich weiß, ich könnte mir gerne was anderes erzählen. Ich bezweifle,
dass das funktioniert. Wenn du natürlich etwas großes Komplexes hast, dann sage ich
da gar nichts gegen. Und gerade für und gerade an Stellen, wo öfters schon mal was in die
Hose gegangen ist. Aber ja, du hast insofern recht. Also meine Erfahrung wirklich mit richtig
großen Anwendungen, in richtig großen Teams hält sich tatsächlich in Grenzen. Aber ich
kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das anders ist. Da hast du ja noch mehr Probleme, wenn
du erst komplett anfängst, wenn du für alles Tests hast. Aber selbst da, selbst in der
Raumfahrt, wo es darum geht, wo irgendwelche Raketen gesteuert werden oder sowas. Da kann
mir keiner erzählen, dass die erst die erste Zeile programmieren, nachdem sie einen Test
dafür haben. Wie darf man sich das vorstellen? Wir haben eigentlich gar keine Ahnung genau,
was wir machen wollen, beziehungsweise mit welchen Libraries, mit welcher Sprache, mit
wie auch immer. Aber bevor wir auch nur anfangen, Tests zu machen, also zu testen, zu evaluieren,
programmieren wir erstmal Tests oder so. Das ergibt doch überhaupt keinen Sinn. Also
ich glaube, die Wahrheit liegt wie immer irgendwo in der Mitte. Ja, es gibt ja noch gar keine
anderen Stellen, weil du hast ja noch gar nicht angefangen zu programmieren. Nee, also
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das wirklich irgendjemand gibt, der das hundertprozentig
durchzieht. Und außerdem ohne, was heißt Gantia-Kramm? Struktogramm, Alter! Ohne Struktogramm
geht schon mal gar nichts. Nassi Schneiderman Struktogramm, bitte schön. Ja, das ist immer
was anderes. Ja gut, wobei, irgendwo musst du ja mal anfangen. Ja, das sehe ich auch
so. Es ist wichtig, dass gerade an den Stellen, wo es büsnestechnisch große Auswirkungen
hat, wenn was kaputt geht oder eben Sachen, die schon öfters mal kaputt gegangen sind,
dass das sowohl logikseitig getestet ist, aber auch nicht nur, also es reicht ja nicht,
wenn du irgendwelche Unit-Tests hast, die dann im Endeffekt gucken, ok, kommt da das
richtige raus, wenn ich das richtige reinstecke, das müssen auch echte Leute testen. Und das
in Kombination ist glaube ich vollkommen ausreichend. Genau, korrekt. Ich sage ja, hundertprozentig
ergibt keinen Sinn. Wenn du eine halbwegs ordentliche Testabdeckung hast, ist das doch
in Ordnung. Von hundertprozent, das ist ja das, was ich meine. Diese dogmatische Sache,
dass du sagst, das muss so sein und ich schreibe keine Zeile, bevor es einen Test gibt, das
kann einfach nicht funktionieren. Ja, aber wie gesagt, da sind wir wieder beim Thema,
das sieht wahrscheinlich jeder ein bisschen anders. Ich würde mich nur wundern, wenn
das wirklich irgendwo so ist. Dankeschön für eine Trillionen Bits, Sebi x86. Bald gibt's
keine Updates mehr für dich. Profitiere von der Cloud, bau Testchamp, einfach Geld
verlangen und random Coverage-Zahlen zurückliefern. Oh, das ist keine schlechte Idee. Der Testchamp,
der Cloudchamp. Es gibt ja Tools, die machen sowas schon für dich, aber die versuchen das
realistisch einzuschätzen. Nach dem Motto, so und so viele Teile von deinem Code sind
von Tests abgedeckt. Das gibt's ja schon, aber das ist ja realitätsbezogen. Die versuchen
ja, rauszubekommen, was wirklich der Fall ist. Aber so ein Random-Test-Tool für irgendwelche
Manager wäre auch nicht verkehrt. Das könnte man denen einfach schicken, so ein Random-Link.
Wenn irgendein Manager hat einen YouTube-Talk gehört, dass Tests wichtig sind und kommt
dann, Jungs, wie hoch ist unsere Testabdeckung? Und ihr denkt euch dann so, ihr wolltet doch
nie, dass wir Tests programmieren. Also schicken wir einfach den Random-Link zum Testchamp,
der Manager macht den Testchamp auf und sieht, aha, 78% Abdeckung. Wunderbar, weiter geht's.
Was ich halt, ja, du hast schon recht, aber ich bin ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht der richtige
Typ für, ich kriege Anfälle, wenn das alles immer zu langsam geht. Ja, das stimmt schon.
Ich gebe dir ja auch vollkommen recht, gerade, sagen wir mal, im medizinischen Bereich oder
was weiß ich, Luftfahrt, Raumfahrt, was auch immer. Gibt es bestimmt noch viel mehr Bereiche.
Insulin, Microcontroller programmieren für irgendwelche Insulinpumpen oder sowas zum
Beispiel. Das ist was, da würde ich auch sagen, hey, das sollte man jetzt vielleicht nicht
auf gut Glück losprogrammieren und dann das Ding mal als Update pushen und hoffen, dass
alles noch funktioniert. Das ist vielleicht nicht die beste Idee. Na gut, Assistenzsysteme
beim Auto, da kommt es ja öfters mal vor, dass die Leute nebenan fahren und dann erst
mal mit ihrem Auto nicht mal weiterfahren können, weil es updaten muss. Wenn du wüsstest,
wie schlecht unsere Software ist. Ja, das kommt auch noch dazu. Du weißt ja nie, ob dein
Test auch wirklich alles abdeckt. Ich glaube, die wenigsten haben Tests für Tests. Was
ich jetzt schon ein paar mal gelesen habe, wo wir aber wirklich weit, weit davon entfernt
sind, aber wo ich mir vorstellen könnte, dass es im medizinischen Bereich und auch Luft,
Raumfahrt und sonst was, also da, wo es wirklich drauf ankommt, dass es wirklich Leute gibt,
die dafür eingestellt werden, Tests zu verifizieren. Also das gibt es ja wirklich. Es gibt wirklich
Unternehmen, die dann irgendwelche Mathematiker und Big Brain Leute einstellen, die verifizieren,
also mit irgendwelchen, frag mich nicht, mathematischen Theorien, die verifizieren, dass der Programmablauf
nur quasi den Weg nehmen kann, der auch, wie soll ich sagen, ne, das ist falsch, was
er nur gewollt ist, der quasi, dass der Programmablauf keinen anderen Weg nehmen kann. Das gibt es.
Also Microsoft hat zum Beispiel sowas für Hyper-V gemacht angeblich. Microsoft hat angeblich
Kernfunktionen von Hyper-V von Mathematikern untersuchen lassen, die mathematisch bewiesen
haben, dass es keine Bugs gibt. Keine Bugs ist natürlich vielleicht ein bisschen missverständlich
ausgedrückt, dass es keine Abweichung vom vorgegebenen Programmablauf gibt. Das heißt
nicht, wenn in dieser Vorgabe ein Logikdenkfehler ist, dass es da nicht auch Bugs geben kann.
Aber das ist klar, das funktioniert ja nicht. Da wird es dann wahrscheinlich relativ teuer
und advanced. Mickey, danke für den Sub. Okay, wir müssen das Video jetzt mal fertig
gucken. Wir sind noch gar nicht durch, ich hab wieder ewig geschwätzt für fünf Minuten
Video.
Person or team to validate the code before it goes out. Another opinion that's kind of
related to testing is that-
Sorry, sorry, sorry. Weil ich es gerade im Chat lese. Cloud. Ja, das stimmt, es gibt
immer noch einige No-Cloud-Policy haben, aber was bei uns jetzt lustig ist, da musst du
dich richtig kecken bei uns auf der Arbeit. Also, sie haben vor ein paar Jahren erzählt
so nach dem Motto Cloud, Cloud, Cloud only. Wir machen nichts mehr ohne Cloud. Cloud ist
das einzig wahre und jeder, der es wagt zu sagen, dass nicht Cloud, der wird ausgepeitscht
so nach dem Motto. Also, das war so die Marschrichtung bei uns auf der Arbeit. Und letztens, vor
einem, ist doch gar nicht lang her, einem Monat oder so, hab ich so gehört, ach ja, übrigens,
No Cloud, äh, äh, nicht No Cloud, äh, übrigens hier, Cloud, Cloud only und sonst was, ähm,
das ist doch nicht so. Also, unser Hauptsystem bleibt jetzt erstmal die nächsten fünf Jahre,
kommt nicht in die Cloud.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, Alter, warum macht ihr immer so eine Attacke und rudert
dann ein halbes Jahr später wieder zurück? Das macht alles nicht glaubwürdiger. Ihr
kennen das vielleicht auch, vielleicht von euch, von der Arbeit, dass oft, dass oft mal,
zumindest bei uns hab ich so den Eindruck, es werden wöchentlich neue Dinger verkündet
und, und, äh, angepriesen, von denen bestimmt 80% niemals wieder erwähnt werden. Ja, zum
Beispiel kommt dann so, ich denk mir jetzt mal ein bisschen was aus, ja, da kommt dann
so nach dem Motto, ihr dürft kein Ticket mehr annehmen ohne xy oder wenn ihr ein Ticket
aufmacht, dann nur noch so und so. Ihr müsst jetzt Zeiterfassung in System a, b, c und
jetzt auch noch in System d machen und blablabla, also irgendwelche, irgendwelche Sachen, so.
Und das Beste, was man bei uns auf der Arbeit mittlerweile machen kann, ist folgendes, wenn,
wenn mal wieder so was Großartiges verkündet wird, du wartest zwei Monate, du wartest zwei
Monate und allem, von allem, also von, muss ich umgekehrt sagen, von den meisten Sachen
hörst du nie wieder was, dann musst du sie auch nicht mal machen, von den Dingern, die
du nach zwei Monaten wieder hörst, die kannst du dann machen. Also das Beste bei uns auf
der Arbeit ist so eine, so, so, erst mal so Pendel ausweichen, erst mal so pendelmäßig
ausweichen, oh, da ist was Neues, eines von 30 Milliarden, 30 Milliarden ganz ultrawichtig
hochpriorisierten, ganz wichtigen, wichtigsten Sachen überhaupt. Also wenn man, wenn man
500 Sachen hat, die alle die wichtigsten Sachen sind, dann ist nichts mehr die wichtigste
Sache. Versteht ihr, wie ich mein? Du kannst nicht zu allem sagen, höchste Priorität,
das ist das wichtigste oder sonst wie, das funktioniert nicht. Es, es, weil dann, wenn,
wenn du das so inflationär verwendest, dein Chef schaut meine Streams, ja, ihr wisst jetzt
aber nicht, was da, was da dran irgendwie nicht, nicht stimmen sollte, ähm, dann hat
das keinen Wert mehr. Also sprich, wenn man zu allem immer sagt, das ist das Wichtigste
oder das ist das Beste oder, keine Ahnung, das ist das, worum jetzt höchste Priorität,
müsst ihr nachgucken, dann ist nichts höchste Priorität. Und das ist auch so eine Falle,
da tappen wir auf der Arbeit öfters rein, dass heute einer ankommt, ah, was weiß ich,
Thema A, höchste Priorität, morgen ist irgendwas anderes jetzt Thema B, höchste Priorität
und wenn man fragst, ja, was ist denn jetzt mit Thema A, ähm, da sagt er, ja, äh, auch
höchste Priorität, das ist ein bisschen wie, das ist ein bisschen wie Tickets, äh, wenn
du Tickets bekommst, die sind ja aus Prinzip immer hoch oder sehr hoch, obwohl die überhaupt
nicht hoch oder sehr hoch sind. Das, das, das klappt nicht, ja. Deswegen ist das Beste,
was man machen kann bei uns, erste Mal, gerade wenn so neue Sachen angekündigt werden,
erste Mal, zwei Monate, die Füße stillhalten und gucken, was davon ist denn noch da, ja,
was, was, was ist denn, was ist denn noch? Was, was, was ist denn noch, ja. Und dann klappt
das. Die wichtigsten Mails sind ja auch immer mit wichtig, genau, genau, genau, weil ja
auch nur wichtige Leute, wichtige Mails schicken, genau. So. Mein Chef weiß, dass das so ist
bei uns. Der hat ja oftmals selbst das Problem, wenn mein Chef mir was sagt, dass ich das
machen soll, dann mach ich das, weil umgedreht muss ich sagen, ich, ich versuch mir dann,
der kümmert sich ja auch um die Sachen, wenn, wenn, wenn ich was sage, wenn wir was sagen,
deswegen versuche ich dann auch dementsprechend auch immer, mich da möglichst schnell drum
zu kümmern, wenn der irgendwas Kurzfristiges hat, aber der hat ja die gleichen Probleme,
die kommen ja auch zu dem und sagen, sag deinen Jungs mal, die müssen jetzt ganz, ganz dringend
was weiß ich noch, Zeiterfassung in System C zusätzlich machen. Nächste Woche keistern
wieder, ah ja, übrigens jetzt doch nicht. Oder hin und her hat er genau das gleiche
Problem, denn ich gehe davon aus, dass der das genauso handhabt, das bloß nicht an
die große Glocke hängt. So, jetzt gucken wir jetzt aber endlich mal, fertig. Also,
der Customer, ah je, also Endkundenkontakt ist was, das vermeide ich erfolgreich seit
über zehn Jahren. Das Problem ist, dass der Customer, je nachdem, was da mit dem Ausbau,
teilweise weiß er selbst nicht, was er eigentlich haben will.
Informatiker im Chat, das haben wir auch schon durch, das haben wir auch schon durch. Lustig,
dass du das schreibst. Wir wechseln jetzt von Zeitschätzung auf Komplexität, aber
nicht auf Story Points, sondern T-Shirt-Kürzen. Ja, ja, das haben wir auch schon durch. Das
war auch mal eine Sache. Das sollten wir T-Shirt, das hatten wir, witzig, dass du das schreibst,
genau das gleiche hatten wir auch schon. Mittlerweile machen wir das nicht mehr. Mittlerweile machen
wir keine T-Shirt-Kürzen mehr. Mittlerweile schreiben wir wieder irgendwelche Zeiten dran,
allerdings sind die Zeitschätzung bei uns immer ziemlich, ziemlich vage. Du sagst dann
so nach dem Motto, Alter, ich weiß doch überhaupt nicht, was ihr von mir wollt. Wie soll ich
denn schätzen, wie lange das dauert? Und dann kommt dann so als Antwort so nach dem
Motto, ja, schätze mal irgendwas. Und das mache ich mittlerweile. Ich schätze einfach
irgendwas. Und oftmals ist es dann so, dass dann irgendeiner kommt und sagt, das können
wir ja nicht machen, das dauert ja so lange. Es ist so wir, es ist einfach so wir. Jetzt
muss ich ja wirklich fertig kommen. Ich unterbreche jetzt nicht, bis das Video fertig ist.
DIVORCE, da muss ich immer an den Typ denken. Ich hab schon wieder vergessen, wie es heißt,
die Jo, I want divorce. Willst du mir nicht weinen? Ihr kennt das 100%. Egal. Ja, ja.
Oh, oh, das ist genau das, was ich, ich glaube, der sagt jetzt genau das gleiche, was ich
auch als Beispiel genommen habe. Man kann, man kann nicht Ja oder Nein sagen. Ja, Readability
ist, würde ich sagen, in den meisten Fällen schon eines der wichtigsten Sachen. Aber aber
es kann durchaus Fälle geben, wo das nicht so ist. Wenn jetzt irgendjemand sagt hier,
das hier muss bis auf die auf den letzten CPU Cycle optimiert sein, dann ist das halt vielleicht
nicht mehr readable oder sondern nicht gut readable.
Ja, das ist das, was ich ja vorhin auch gemeint habe. Genau. Richtig, das kommt auch noch
dabei. Nein, aber ganz im Ernst, ganz, ganz im Ernst. Also jetzt mal, jetzt mal, jetzt
mal Hand aufs Herz. Was ist besser lesbar? Okay, das ist das ist auch ein doofes Beispiel.
Es gibt ja auch eine vor each Schleife mittlerweile in JavaScript. Also ich persönlich mag ja
die traditionelle Lupe Geschichte lieber als die Lupe mit irgendwelchen Lambda Dingern
hinten dran. Gerade nachdem ja mittlerweile JavaScript auch so was wie ein richtiges
vor each hat, dann ist mir das da unten aber jetzt vielleicht nicht als als zählen wir
zählen, sondern als vor each. Also als ausgeschriebenes vor each ist mir das lieber als das mit der
Situation like that. I start by writing the most readable code and if performance does
in fact become a problem, then I may optimize it in the future, but ninety percent of the
time it's too insignificant. Nein, nicht das chat. Niemals das vor each vor each. JavaScript
hat auch jetzt vor wie heißt das vor each oft oder sowas. Oder war das C plus plus
bring ich das jetzt gerade durcheinander? Ja JavaScript hat auch sowas. Achso meine Suche
ist ja kaputt. Vor oft ist es vor oft. Jaja genau genau. Hier das da. Also okay. Was was
was besser? Hier was weiß ich? Ja das fange ich schon mit Notepad an. Ich muss Notepad
machen, weil ich kann Visual Studio Code nicht aufmachen, weil ich keine Suche habe.
So also das da. Lol wie was auch immer. Oder das da. Also ich persönlich bin ja für das
da. Ich bin ja für vote. Okay okay. Äh Moment. Wir machen eine Umfrage. Alles klar machen
wir aber. Äh aus kaputt. Warum geht das nicht? Ah ja hier. Ja das kann man jetzt. Das kann
man jetzt schlecht hier rein copy pasten. So Umfrage. Zack. Beste Umfrage. Was? Ähm
ich hab die Hälfte nicht mitcopiert. Alter. Ich hab die Hälfte nicht mitcopiert. Aber
ihr wisst was ich meine. Ja. Also ich persönlich bin für das. Das mag alles auch seine Daseinsberechtigung
haben. Ist auf jeden Fall Geschmackssache. Zum Beispiel, dass du hier keinen Break drin
machen kannst. Na doch du kannst einen Break machen. Du kannst Return machen, kommt das
gleiche raus. Die wichtige Frage ist doch Range, Base, Loop versus Normal. Äh eigentlich
wenn ich kein Index brauche immer immer for each. Das stimmt. Das ist richtig. Das ist
richtig. Das ist richtig. Ja. Wenn du es vorher noch filtern willst, umtransformieren
und dann for each machen, ist es vielleicht sinnvoll. Wobei man das da, das da könnte
man genauso. Könnte man auch da reinschreiben. Vielleicht ist es nicht so schön aber. Ich
mein. Ansonsten hast du halt das Problem. Einen Moment das da sollte man vielleicht
weglassen so hier. Ansonsten hast du halt das Problem, dass was weiß ich, dass du dann
hier noch irgendwelche Dinger dazwischen machst. So bla bla bla. Das macht es dann auch nicht
gerade übersichtlicher. Es ist Geschmackssache, ja. Gut, gut dass wir das jetzt geklärt haben.
Das macht man wieder dicht. Was hältst du davon? Okay.
Was? Was? Function and returning closure. Okay. Ja. Wieso? Was soll ich davon? Also
mein das da finde ich vielleicht ein bisschen schwer. Das hier finde ich recht eindeutig.
Wobei, ja gut, das kann man machen. Warum nicht? Sonderlich, sagen wir so sonderlich lesbar
mag es jetzt vielleicht nicht sein. Schau rechts. Ja. Ach so. Bäh.
Das ist mir zu hoch jetzt. Big brain, zu low IQ Zeit heute Morgen. Das geht jetzt nicht.
Das fällt mir ein. Ich hab Hunger. Ich muss gleich was essen. Aber wir gucken jetzt noch
ein paar Witz. Was ist das? Playstation 4 Emulation auf dem PC ist da. Da bin ich ja
mal gespannt. Ich mein PS4 auf dem PC emulieren ist ja an sich schon eigentlich ein bisschen
der Witz. Weil die PS4 ist ein PC. Das ist ganz stinknormale x86 Hardware. Oder x86 64
Hardware. Kiko Dankeschön für den Sub. Sechs Monate. Huge subscriptions hier. Oh ja, das stimmt.
Das ist das gleiche. Das muss ich jetzt auch noch mal ganz kurz was zu sagen. Ja, das ist
das gleiche wie wenn du viel Link verwendest in C-Sharp. Das durchläuft auch gerne mehrfach
alles. Ja. Da muss man aufpassen. Generell sind diese so ein bisschen funktional angehauten
Sachen. Wenn man sie falsch verwendet oftmals ziemlich lahm. Gucken wir mal. PS4 Emulation.
Ganz dumm Schwätzer. Das sind die Hersteller vielleicht. Ich lad mir ja auch keine ROMs
runter. Ich hab ja alle meine ROMs selbstverständlich selbst gerippt von original physischen Datenträger.
Ihr bestimmt auch. Was anderes würde ja keiner machen.
Manche Sachen würden überhaupt nicht funktionieren. Die ganze beispielsweise, weiß nicht ob einer
von euch vielleicht ein bisschen A Link to the Past Randomizer guckt. Das würde überhaupt
nicht funktionieren ohne Emulation.
Es gibt ja auch nicht so viel Grund aktuell das auf dem PC zu emulieren. PS4 kostet nicht
viel. PS4 kriegste noch überall. Und es gibt nicht so wahnsinnig viele Spiele würde ich
sagen die man unbedingt haben will die exklusiv sind. Also die letzte Konsolengeneration ist
ja quasi die Konsolengeneration wo die Exklusivität ein bisschen verloren gegangen ist. Zu Xbox
360 und PS3 Zeiten war viel viel mehr. Ich kann es euch leider nicht belegen vielleicht
erzähle ich scheiß ja. Aber gefühlt zumindest ist das so. Dass viel viel mehr Sachen damals
noch Konsolen exklusiv waren was heute auch auf dem PC kommt.
Sogar so Sachen wie wie wie ist das der DHL Simulator. Death Stranding genau. Sind ja
mittlerweile auch auf dem PC am Start.
Es gibt ja auch nicht so wahnsinnig viele Spiele wo die Exklusivität ein bisschen verloren
ist.
Spindev hat endlich seinen Emulator für das Publikum eröffnet
und eine Compatibilitätsschicht eröffnet, die wirklich illustriert, was eigentlich spielbar ist.
Jetzt, 2019, hat Spindev ein YouTube Video eröffnet, das einiges von dem Prozess gezeigt hat
und es wurde gebootiert und gespielt, wie die Mega Man Legacy Collection und Stardew Valley.
Aber es war ein ziemlich guter Start.
So, dann warum habe ich heute Spindev eröffnet? Das Publikum hat eine Compatibilitätsschicht eröffnet,
und es befindet sich an ca. 50 Titeln, die man im Spiel bekommen kann und somit spielbar sind.
Und viele andere, die man in den Intro-Screen anbieten kann, bevor sie kraschen.
Und da gibt es YouTube-Videos, die bereits im Spiel zeigen, wie man die Potenziale und was man mit dem Spiel sehen kann.
Aber wie immer wollte ich das für mich aufsetzen und schauen, wie es aussieht.
Die Ergebnisse sind ziemlich primitiv, aber sie sind sehr erlaubt.
Und man sollte daran achten, dass es sehr viel in den Prozess geht.
Und man sollte definitiv nicht darauf achten, dass es sehr viel in den Prozess geht.
Was ist mit diesem Charakter? Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das jetzt genau nennt. Community.
Also das ist teilweise höchst verstörend, was ich da gesehen habe schon.
Ich sehe, Razer kennt sich da aus.
Ja gut, dass das läuft. Ich meine, geil, kann ich ein Re-Release des NES-Games im PS4-Emulator spielen, was schlechter aussieht als immer ein NES-Emulator?
Okay, aber ich will das jetzt nicht schlecht machen, weil das ist natürlich, wie sagt man so schön, Basics-Sachen.
Also Pionierarbeit oder ja, Grundlagenforschung, könnte man sagen, was PS4-Emulationen angeht.
Daraus kann natürlich noch mehr werden.
Was selbst kompiliert, oder? Ja, sehr gute Idee.
Das ist für Windows unter Linux und nicht für Linux unter Windows. Du meinst per WSL vielleicht, ja.
Aber mit grafischen Sachen unter WSL. Das Ja des Linux-Desktops, genau.
Hört sich etwas holprig an zu installieren.
Das ist ja wie beim PS1-Emulator, wo du dir bis heute noch aus dubiosen Quellen-Bios-Sachen runterladen musst.
Ach du Scheiße! Ach du Scheiße!
Okay, das dürfte für 99% der Weltbevölkerung nicht machbar sein.
In anderen Worten, ein E-Boot.bin ist das Exekutable, das es sich für die Spiele beginnt.
Das es unter Linux-Ondi läuft, ist vielleicht gar nicht so abwegig. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob es seit der ersten Playstation ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall seit der PS3 so.
Okay, unten drunter natürlich mit Custom-Drivern und sonst was. Der wird wahrscheinlich irgendwelche FreeBSD-Compatibility-Layer für Linux verwenden.
Custom angepasst für irgendwelche PS4-Geschichten. Deswegen kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen, dass es niemals richtig unter Windows laufen wird.
KVM QEMO ist halt lahm im Vergleich zu dem Wine-Ansatz.
Außer dem Wine-KVM ist für unterschiedliche CPU-Architektur. Das brauchst du ja nicht. Das ist ja das gleiche in deinem PC wie in der PS4.
Du kannst einen KVM laufen lassen mit irgendeinem BSD drin. Das wird es aber wahrscheinlich auch nicht einfacher machen als ein Custom-Layer für Linux. Ich weiß nicht, wie es funktioniert. Kein Schimmer.
Ich kann jetzt auch nur raten. PS4-Docker, genau. Deine Meinung zu WSL? Ja, notwendiges, ich will nicht sagen übel, aber notwendige Sache, weil viele Sachen unter Windows sind halt einfach nicht gescheit benutzbar. Daily-mäßig.
Wenn man nicht gerade ganz hardcore Windows verdorben ist schon. Deswegen ist WSL notwendig. Ich persönlich bevorzuge immer noch komplette Linux-Installationen. Oder aber, so wie hier, Linux in der VM und Windows auf dem Host.
Und es gibt wahrscheinlich eine einfache Art, dass jemand mir sagt, dass ich das gemacht hätte, aber das ist die Art, wie es für mich funktioniert. Aber in jedem Fall, wenn du ein paar Spiele hast, ist es wirklich ein Fall, in den Spiel zu starten.
Das ist nicht sehr user-freundlich, aber es soll es nicht sein. Dieser Emulator ist sehr früh in der Entwicklung. Es gibt keine GUI oder UI. Und es gibt viele Hubs, die man durchdrehen muss. Wenn man keine Zugang zu einem moddierten PS4 hat, kann man nicht sehr weit kommen.
So, let's test some games. Now, what games did I test and how do they perform? Well, the first game that I tried was Dead Cells. And I gotta say, this was a great first impression, because it loaded really fast into the title screen and the game itself is quite playable.
But of course, you'll know the graphical issues that are present. The speed and performance running on my three-year-old laptop is very impressive. And not to mention, the sound emulation is really excellent. Now, you can tell that this emulator has a ton of care and attention put into it. And again, this is a pretty good start.
Now, I also tried Sonic Mania. Now, I saw a video of Sonic Mania running and it looked excellent running at full speed, albeit with color palette.
Das hat schon Sinn. Ich dachte aber am Anfang auch immer, dass es so rum sein müsste eigentlich. Klingt logischer, ist es aber im Endeffekt nicht. Wo waren wir denn jetzt hier stehen geblieben?
Alter, was hat er denn immer mit Samsonic Zeug? Ohje, ohje. Okay, lass mich raten, Menü startet danach, Crash.
This game is not going to run. I'm not really sure why it would say in-game, but it was on the list anyway. So much to my surprise, when I tried out Dark Souls Remastered, it loaded into the title screen and allowed me to enter the menu and create a character.
And it even loads into the intro sequence, which I think is just video files or Bing files. It has to be. I don't think this is real-time 3D.
And at the end of the intro sequence, it actually got in-game. And as you can see, the emulation has not locked up. You can still press your button inputs.
In-game ist vielleicht sehr wohlwollend ausgedrückt. Ich glaube PS3 Emulation funktioniert bis heute nicht.
Ist aber auch ein schwieriges Thema. Also ich glaube eine PS4 Laufwege zu machen auf dem PC ist einfacher als eine PS3. Echt, gibt es jetzt? Wie haben die das denn gemacht?
Also Architektur-mäßig ist eine PS4 deutlich näher am PC dran als eine PS3.
Und die Emulation der Erinnerungen klingt sehr kompliziert für mich. Und ich würde gerne mehr lernen, wie das alles funktioniert.
Das andere ist, dass die PS4 keine OpenGL, Vulkan oder DirectX nutzt. Sie hat ihr eigenes proprietary Graphics-API, known als GNM.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was er mir mitteilen möchte.
Aber ihr wisst ja, was ich ganz cool finde daran jetzt. Ich glaube mit sowas, gerade durch Graphik, irgendwelche Glitches oder sonst wie,
bekommt man einen ganz guten Eindruck darüber, wie manche Games intern funktionieren.
Also ich glaube mit sowas, gerade durch Graphik, irgendwelche Glitches oder sonst wie,
Ich glaube nicht, dass das die Hitboxen sind, die man hier sieht. Das sind einfach die Transparenz, die nicht funktioniert.
Also wir sehen, dass wir nicht viel sehen, dass das eigentlich nicht richtig funktioniert. Aber es hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, weil ich habe da vorher noch nie was von gehört.
Was haben wir denn sonst jetzt hier noch?
Battlefield 2042 vs. Bad Company 2 vs. Battlefield 3 Early Graphics Comparsion. Was willst du denn da groß kompären? Ah, das ist eine gute Idee.
Ach, der kompärt Dinger von Maps, die es da gibt. Ja, okay, das ist tatsächlich ganz, ganz nice.
Das sind doch Bots, oder? Ja, du siehst, du siehst Bad Company 2 schon das Alter an.
Aber eins muss man sagen, Bad Company 2 sieht immer noch ganz gut aus. Auch Battlefield 3 sieht echt noch gut brauchbar aus.
Du siehst schon, dass das alt ist, aber das sieht schon okay aus.
Übrigens, das C4 fliegt überhaupt nicht richtig. Das C4 in Bad Company 2 kannst du mit springen und nach oben, kannst du bis dahinten, also du konntest in Bad Company 2 ohne Probleme, wenn hier hinten was stand, dann C4 hinschmeißen mit Anlauf und springen und Maus hoch.
Das C4 ist ewig weit geflogen in Bad Company 2.
Du siehst, du siehst schon, gerade auch bei den Partikeleffekten, du siehst schon das Alter.
Ja, doch, doch, das siehst du schon. Es ist schon ein ziemlicher Unterschied, aber es ist nicht so, dass Bad Company 2 schlecht aussieht, oder so. Es sieht durchaus brauchbar aus.
Gut, da kannst du jetzt nicht allzu viel bei ausmachen.
Ich meine, ihr müsst euch nur mal den Boden angucken. Guckt euch mal den Boden hier an und auch hier, dass das nach Rinden aussieht. Man sieht schon das Alter.
Aber es sieht wirklich, das sieht echt in Ordnung aus. So, jetzt brauchen wir noch Battlefield 3, Comparison, wie auch immer das richtig heißt.
Caspian Border. Gut, da muss ich euch jetzt sagen, es ist wirklich nicht viel Unterschied zwischen dem und Battlefield 3.
Also da ist jetzt wirklich nicht viel Unterschied. Wobei man halt aber auch sagen muss, gerade durch die Kompression und hier so starke Vegetation sieht das unter YouTube nicht so geil aus.
Ja, das sieht jetzt schon besser aus. Also die Bäume sind deutlich detaillierter und mehr, aber so eine große Unterschiede ist es nicht.
Die Felsen sehen genauso aus, eckig wie in Battlefield 3. Aber gut, es ist ja wahrscheinlich auch mehr oder weniger Import aus Battlefield 3.
Guckt mal, so eine große Unterschiede ist es nicht. Es ist halt dieser grau-blau-matte Look von Battlefield 3.
Was ist das für eine Auflösung? Guckt mal die Minimap. Guckt mal die Minimap. Das ist ja gar nichts mehr drauf.
Also da muss ich jetzt ehrlich sagen, ist der Unterschied eher subtil. Was denkst du wegen der Verschiebung?
Okay, das sieht natürlich deutlich besser aus, die Waffenmodels. Ich bin der Meinung, mir ist es lieber, das Game kommt in einem brauchbaren Zustand raus, zumal wir eh das gleiche kriegen.
Den Stand, den wir dann zu Release bekommen, ist der Stand, den wir jetzt bekommen hätten, mit Day 1 Patch und 1-2 großen Patches. Also mir ist es lieber, das kommt spielbarer raus.
Ja, das stimmt schon, Beleuchtung ist ein großer Unterschied, aber das kann man, finde ich, immer recht schwer beurteilen, weil Battlefield 3 diesen komischen, diesen matten, grau-blauen Filter drüber hat.
Das sieht Tageslicht in Battlefield 3, sieht halt nicht so richtig Tageslicht-mäßig aus.
Je nachdem, was die machen, kann ich mir schon vorstellen, dass die Verspätung deutlich zur Spielbarkeit beitragen kann. Moment, man konnte das Ding umschießen in Battlefield 3, ging das? Das war mir so gar nicht bewusst.
Das ist doch nicht der große Mast, ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das umschießen kann. Oder sind es die Reste vom großen Mast?
Ja gut, also die Beleuchtung ist halt hier unterhalb der Filter. Hier sieht halt grün, wirklich grün aus, ja, aber ansonsten, also die Unterschiede, die Waffenmodels sind halt viel, viel besser. Das sieht man sofort.
Aber ansonsten ist das doch schon nichts. Es ist recht subtil. Die Bäume sehen natürlich auch viel, viel fülliger aus als die komischen Dinger hier in Battlefield 3.
Aber Welten sind das nicht.
Aber sind die Disc-Versionen nicht schon lange gepresst? Das mag schon sein, aber die Disc-Versionen bringen dir ja nichts, weil du das nicht spielen kannst. Selbst wenn du jetzt irgendwie, also erstens, keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt und zweitens, wenn das so ist, musst du eh erstmal 200 GB Day One Patch runterladen, wenn du das Spiel das erste Mal startest.
Also es ist egal, was auf der Disc drauf ist. Falls es überhaupt schon Discs gibt.
Tribolon, Dankeschön, 22 Monate Subscription.
Grafik wird runtergeschraubt, dass man viel FPS hat, korrekt.
Das war ja lustig. EA hat mich ja angeschrieben wegen Spiel-Playtest und so. Und das habe ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt. Und die haben gesagt, ich bräuchte einen anderen PC, weil ich eine 1080 Ti habe und die Mindestanforderung wäre eine 2060.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Meine Grafikkarte ist 50-60% schneller als eine 2060.
Es wird nicht RTX OLED, garantiert nicht. Es wird ja auch auf AMD Karten laufen.
Ja gut, hier ist der Unterschied jetzt schon. Also gerade von der Vegetation ist der Unterschied schon deutlich sichtbar, dass es viel detaillierter ist in Battlefield 2042.
Aber Battlefield 3 sieht immer noch ziemlich gut aus.
Es wird keine Discs mehr geben. Ja, aber PS4 und PS5 Versionen, das muss doch eine Disc sein.
Da hast du nicht so viel Speicher wie auf dem PC.
Disc ist nur Download, auch auf der Playstation, das wäre ziemlich auf Fail.
Man musste erstmal die Hälfte an der Platte dafür opfern.
Battlefield Mobile? Was? Was ist Battlefield Mobile? Was ist das?
Ist das ein Battlefield 3 Reskin fürs Handy oder was?
Für die China-Chinesen? Das sieht original aus wie Battlefield 3, vom Logo her und so.
Also vom Style her. Okay, das ist Basar nur in schlecht.
Blond Basar in schlecht mit Fahrzeugen. Ah gut, Conquest. Das ist Battlefield 3 oder? Das ist Battlefield 3 für Mobile.
WTF, warum? Na gut, weil es Geld bringt. Was ist das für eine Frage?
How to Google it? Okay, das gucken wir uns jetzt noch an. Oh Leute, das muss ich euch zeigen. Ich will mir das Video nicht angucken.
Auf dem Tablet abends, als ich noch ein bisschen Streams geguckt habe. Alter, das ist wie ein hyperaktiver Let's Player, nur auf der Kommandozeile.
Sowas habe ich noch nie gesehen. Ich kann mir das keine 10 Minuten angucken, aber es hat was.
Es ist ohne Scheiß hyperaktiver Let's Player, nur auf der Kommandozeile.
Das ist so wie eine YouTube Let's Play-Persönlichkeit, die funny Garry's Mods früher gemacht hat, jetzt nur auf der Kommandozeile.
Total vieres Zeug. Das ist quasi wie XQC auf der Kommandozeile.
Was bin ich sehen? Das könnte der von Netflix sein. Das wird später noch schlimmer.
Guckt euch mal die Tastatur an. Das ist so Hipster-Style, keine Ahnung.
Das ist quasi wie ein hyperaktiver Let's Play-Live-Streamer, nur auf der Kommandozeile.
Das ist so Hipster-Style, keine Ahnung.